[Music]
hey everyone welcome to this video
tutorial on ethical hacking full course
by simplylearn
in this full course you will learn all
about ethical hacking even if you're new
to ethical hacking it's okay as this
full course will familiarize you with
the concept of ethical hacking
here we will learn the importance of
ethical hacking what exactly ethical
hacking is
the ethical hacking process and who an
ethical hacker is
you will also be acquainted with a few
cyber attacks with a hands-on demo for
reach
for this crash course we have our
experienced instructor bipin who will
take you through the various topics
he will also give you an insight into
the popular ch exam and guide you on
your journey as an ethical hacker
you can learn all of these topics in
under 3 hours
we will be starting off this crash
course with an interesting animated
video on ethical hacking but before we
begin make sure to subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
we humans are highly tech savvy in
today's times
with the extensive use of the internet
and modern technologies
there is a massive challenge in
protecting all our digital data
such as net banking information account
credentials
and medical reports to name a few have
you heard about the deadly wannacry
ransomware attack
the attack happened in may 2017 in asia
and then it spread across the world
within a day
more than 230 000 computers were
infected
across 150 countries the wannacry
cryptoworm
encrypted the data and locked the users
out of their systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of 300 to 600
dollars in bitcoin
the users who used the unsupported
version of microsoft windows
and those who hadn't installed the
security update of april 2017
were targeted in this attack the
wannacry attack took a toll on every
sector
top tier organizations like hitachi
nissan
and fedex had to put their businesses on
hold
as their systems were affected too now
this is what you call a cyber attack to
prevent such attacks
cyber security is implemented we can
define cyber security as the practice of
protecting networks
programs computer systems and their
components
from unauthorized digital attacks these
illegal attacks are often referred to as
hacking
hacking refers to exploiting weaknesses
in a computer network
to obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems
this is a misconception that hacking is
always wrong
there are hackers who work with
different motives
let's have a look at three different
types of hackers black hat hackers
are individuals who illegally hack into
a system for monetary gain
on the contrary we have white hat
hackers who exploit the vulnerabilities
in a system
by hacking into it with permission in
order to defend the organization
this form of hacking is absolutely legal
and ethical
hence they are also often referred to as
ethical hackers
in addition to these hackers we also
have the grey hat hackers
as the name suggests the color gray is a
blend of both white and black
these hackers discover vulnerabilities
in a system and report it
to the system's owner which is a good
act
but they do this without seeking the
owner's approval
sometimes grey hat hackers also ask for
money in return for the spotted
vulnerabilities
now that you have seen the different
types of hackers let's understand
more about the hacking that is legal and
valid ethical hacking
through an interesting story dan runs a
trading company
he does online training with the money
his customers invest
everything was going well and dan's
business was booming
until a hacker decided to hack the
company's servers
the hacker stole the credentials of
various trading accounts
he asked for a lump sum ransom in
exchange for the stolen credentials
dan took the hacker's words lightly and
didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts
and dan was liable to pay back the
customers
dan lost a lot of money and also the
trust of his customers
after this incident dan gave a lot of
thought as to what could have gone wrong
with the security infrastructure in his
company
he wished there was someone from his
company who could have run a test attack
to see how vulnerable systems were
before the hacker penetrated into the
network
this was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker
and identifies the vulnerabilities in
his network
before an outsider does to do this job
he hired an ethical hacker john
john was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker
in no time he spotted several
vulnerabilities in dan's organization
and closed all the loopholes hiring an
ethical hacker helped dan protect his
customers from further attacks in the
future
this in turn increased the company's
productivity
and guarded the company's reputation so
now you know hacking is not always bad
john
in this scenario expose the
vulnerabilities in the existing network
and such hacking is known as ethical
hacking
ethical hacking is distributed into six
different phases
let us look at these phases step by step
with respect to how john our ethical
hacker
will act before launching an attack the
first step john takes is to gather all
the necessary information
about the organization's system that he
intends to attack
this step is called reconnaissance he
uses tools like
nmap and h-ping for this purpose john
then tries to spot the vulnerabilities
if any in the target system
using tools like nmap and expose
this is the scanning phase now that he
has located the vulnerabilities
he then tries to exploit them this step
is known
as gaining access after john makes his
way through the organization's networks
he tries to maintain his access for
future attacks by installing back doors
in the target system
the metasploit tool helps him with this
this phase is called maintaining access
john is a brilliant hacker hence he
tries his best
not to leave any evidence of his attack
this is the fifth phase
clearing tracks we now have the last
phase
that is reported in this phase john
documents a summary of his entire attack
the vulnerabilities he spotted the tools
he used
and the success rate of the attack
looking into the report
dan is now able to take a call and see
how to protect his organization
from any external cyber attacks don't
you all think john is an asset to any
organization
if you want to become an ethical hacker
like john then there are a few skills
that you need to acquire
first and foremost you need to have a
good knowledge of operating environments
such as windows linux unix and
macintosh you must have reasonably good
knowledge of programming languages
such as html php python
sql and javascript networking
is the base of ethical hacking hence you
should be good at it
ethical hackers should be well aware of
security laws so that they don't
misuse their skills finally you must
have a global certification on ethical
hacking to successfully bag a position
of an ethical hacker
like john few examples of ethical
hacking certification
are certified ethical hacker
certification ceh
comptia pintest plus and licensed
penetration tester certification
to name a few simplylearn provides a
cybersecurity expert masters program
that will equip you with all the skills
required by a cybersecurity expert
you could have a look at it by clicking
the link in the description
the endless growth of technologies in
this area is directly proportional to
the number of cyber crimes
cyber crimes are estimated to cost six
trillion dollars in 2021
hence to tackle these cyber crimes
organizations are continuously on the
lookout for cyber security professionals
the average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker is 91 000
in the u.s and approximately rupees
seven lakhs
in india so what are you waiting for
get certified and become an ethical
hacker like john
and put an end to the cyber attacks in
the world
so let's talk about hacking and what
exactly hacking is
hacking refers to exploiting weaknesses
in a computer network to obtain
unauthorized access
to information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems now
here there are some keywords that we
need to understand
first and foremost exploit when you are
exploiting weaknesses
weaknesses are technically called
vulnerabilities which are basically
design flaws
misconfiguration errors usage of default
usernames and passwords which
have not been modified so any
misconfiguration
or anything that has been left behind by
a security administrator
that can be misused which means
exploited by a hacker
to gain unauthorized access so the next
term is unauthorized access
something that you're not allowed to do
and when you say a hacker is a person
who tries to hack
it's basically a person with malicious
intent
trying to gain access to a system or a
resource that they are not
authorized to access in the first place
how do they do it they find a
vulnerability that is a weakness or a
flaw
and then they misuse it to gain access
to that particular
network so here in the diagram you can
see that a sender
on the left hand side is trying to send
some data to the receiver on the right
hand side
the hacker would try to gain
unauthorized access to the transmission
that is being sent and would try to
capture the data packets and read the
secrets within
let's look at a business case scenario
into hacking now there is an
organization
everybody is going around their own
business when they realize that their
systems may have been compromised now
they're trying to look at the customer
data to ensure that that has not been
compromised and
trying to assure the customers however
they do realize
that some customer data has been lost
and even
the company reports have been modified
as well now this is the scenario where
there have been some security controls
in place and those controls have been
identified
they realized that there is an attack
that has happened and based on that
attack
they have realized that the data has now
been compromised and the records have
been modified
by the hacker which means that the data
is no longer trustworthy
and thus cannot be used by the business
for any legal transactions
so then the hacker gives a call to the
organization or gets connected to the
organization demanding a ransom
for the data to be replaced to be taken
back into the original state where it
was trusted
and thus the organization can utilize it
for business transactions
the organization has probably no backup
so they decide that they want to
pay the lump sum to the hacker to
restore that data so that they can
continue on with the business
does money exchanges and the hacker is
able to restore that data
and the business continues that as usual
however
the activity here of a hacker trying to
leverage
the misconfiguration of the weaknesses
in the organization's
security thus being able to hack them
and make these ransomware demands so the
company then
wants to figure out even if having a
security system in place
how was the hacker able to hack their
systems thus
one of the employees comes up with a
brilliant idea of identifying
vulnerabilities
in the network uh to proactively search
for any flaws that have been left behind
so that they can plug those laws and
nobody can misuse them
thus they figure out that they want to
hire an ethical hacker
who would help them identify the
security posture of the organization
identify the weaknesses
vulnerabilities and flaws and help them
remedy those
laws so that in future scenarios these
scenarios
will not happen so before we go into an
ethical hacker
let's understand what are the types of
hackers so
what are the types of hackers hacker is
a technically skilled person
who is very adept with computers they
have good programming skills they
understand how operating system works
they understand how networks work they
understand how to identify flaws and
vulnerabilities within all of these
aspects
and then they understand and know how to
misuse these flaws
to get a outcome which would be
detrimental to the health of the
organization
so there are six type of hackers that
have been identified black hat hackers
white hat hackers grey hat script
kiddies nation's players sponsored
hackers
and activists so black hat hackers are
basically basically
uh the malicious hackers who have
malicious intent
and have criminalistic tendencies they
want to
harm the organization by hacking into
their infrastructure by destroying their
infrastructure by destroying
the data so that they can gain from it
from a monetary perspective
these guys are also known as crackers
the main aspect of these
people are that they have malicious
intent they try to do unauthorized
activities
and they try it for personal gain
another important aspect to remember is
that a black hat hacker will always try
to hide their identity
they will spoof their online digital
identity by masking it by
spoofing their ip addresses mac
addresses and try to remain anonymous on
the network a white attacker on the
other hand
is also an ethical hacker or a security
analyst who is an individual
who will do exactly the same thing that
a black hat hacker would do
minus the malicious intent plus the
intent of helping the organization
identifying the flaws
and remedying them so that nobody else
can misuse those vulnerabilities so they
are authorized
to act on the company's behalf they are
authorized to do that activity which
would help the company identify those
flaws
and thus help the company mitigate those
flaws improving on their security
portion
so these uh these kind of security
experts or ethical hackers
would help organizations defend
themselves against unauthorized attacks
greyhead hackers is a blend of both
white hat and black hat hackers so
here they can work defensively and
offensively both they can accept
contracts
from organizations to increase their
security posture
at the same time they can also get
themselves involved in malicious
activities towards other organizations
to personally gain or benefit from them
by doing unauthorized activity
script kitties are people uh who are
technically
not much aware about what hacking is
they rely on existing tools that have
been created by other hackers
they have no technical knowledge of what
they're doing it's just a hit or miss
for them so they just get their hands on
a tool they try to execute those tools
uh if the hack works it works otherwise
it doesn't so these people are basically
who are noobs or newbies who are trying
to learn hacking or
just people who with malicious intent
who just want to have some fun
or trying to impress people around then
we have the nation
or the state-sponsored hackers as the
name suggests these hackers are
sponsored by their government now
this may not be a legitimate job but
most of the governments do have
hackers enrolled in their pay on
on their organizations to spy on their
enemies to spy on various countries
and try to figure out the aspirations of
those countries so this is basically a
spying activity
where you're technically trying to get
access to other countries resources
and then try to spy on them to figure
out what their activities have been
or what their future plans have been and
then we have the hacktivist
who's an individual who has a political
agenda to promote and they promote it by
doing hacking so
uh these guys what is the difference
between a black hat hacker and an
activist
the black hat hacker may try to hide
their identity a hacktivist
will claim responsibility of what they
have done so for them it's a political
agenda political cause
and they will try to hack various
organizations to promote
their cause they would probably do this
by defacing the website
and posting the messages that they want
to promote on these websites
so what exactly is ethical hacking then
we have discussed the types of hackers
we have identified a malicious hacker as
a black hat hacker with the intent
of doing harm to an organization's
network for personal gain
we have discussed what the ethical
hacker is so an ethical hacker
would be doing the same activity but in
an authorized manner
so they would have legal contracts that
they would be signing with the
organization
it would give them a definite scope of
what they are allowed to do and what
they are not allowed to do and the
ethical hackers would function within
those scopes
would try to execute those test
scenarios where they would be able to
identify those flaws
or those system vulnerabilities and then
they would be submitting a report
to the management of what they have
found they would also help the
management to mitigate or to resolve
those weaknesses
so that nobody else can misuse them
later on they might use the same
techniques and the same tools that black
hat hackers do
however the main difference here is that
these guys are authorized to do that
particular activity
they're doing it in a controlled manner
with the intent of helping the
organization
and not with the intent of personal
gains so who's an ethical hacker
again an ethical hacker is a highly
intelligent highly educated person who
knows how computers function
how programming languages work how
operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
adept
at computing they understand the
architecture they understand
how various components in a computer
work they can troubleshoot those
components
and they can basically be very good with
programming
as well now when i say programming we
don't want the ethical hacker to be a
good developer of applications we want
them to understand programming in such a
way that they can create scripts they
can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
trojans or exploits which should help
them achieve
the objective that they have set out for
so uh here you can see
the ethical hacker there are individuals
who perform a security assessment of the
companies with the permission of
concerned authorities so what is a
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization
by identifying what security controls
are in place how they have been
configured
and if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves
so an organization will hire a hethical
hacker they they would give the ethical
hacker the information
about what information is or what
security controls
what firewalls now what idss ips's
introducing detection or intuition
prevention systems anti-viruses are
already in place
and then they will ask the ethical
hacker to figure out a way to bypass
these mechanisms and see if they can
still hack the organization
what is the need of an ethical hacker
the need of an ethical hacker is
proactive security the ethical hacker
would identify
all the existing flaws in an
organization and
try to resolve those laws to help secure
the organization
from black hat hackers so ethical
hackers would prevent hackers from
cracking into an organization's network
by securing the organization by
improving on their security
on a periodic basis and they would also
try to identify system vulnerabilities
network vulnerabilities or application
level vulnerabilities that would have
been missed
or have already been missed and then
tried to figure out a way of
plugging them or resolving them so that
they cannot be misused
by other hackers they would also analyze
and enhance an organization security
policies
now what are policies policies are
basically documents that have been
created by an organization
of rules that all the employees need to
follow to ensure that the security of an
organization is maintained
for example a password policy a password
policy would help
users in an organization to adhere to
the standards
the organization has identified for a
password complexity
for example a password when a user is
creating them
should adhere to standards where they
are using random words
they are they contain the alphabet a
through z
uppercase and lowercase 0 through 9 as
numerics
and special characters and they're
randomized so that the password becomes
much
more stronger to prevent from brute
force attacks so what would an ethical
hacker do at this point in time they
would try to test the
strength of the passwords to see if
brute force attacks or dictionary
attacks
are possible and if any of these
passwords can be cracked they will
ensure that
all the employees are following the
policies and all the passwords are
as secured as the policies want them to
be if there are any gaps in the policies
or the implementation of the policy it
is the ethical hackers responsibility to
identify those gaps
and warn the organization about it
similarly they would also try to protect
any personal information any data that
is owned by the organization that is
critical for the functioning of the
organization
and they will try to protect it by from
falling into
the hacker's hands now what are the
skills that are required of an ethical
hacker
these are the following skills so first
and foremost they should have good
knowledge with operating systems
such as windows linux unix and mac now
when we say knowledge about operating
systems it's not only about how to
use those operating systems but how to
troubleshoot those operating systems
how these operating systems work how
these operating systems need to be
configured how can they be secured
for example securing an operating system
is not only installing a firewall and an
antivirus but you need to configure
permissions on an operating system
of what users are allowed to do and what
users are not allowed to do
for example limiting the installation of
applications
how are we going to do that we need to
go into the system center the security
center of windows
and we need to configure security
parameters over there of what are
acceptable softwares and what are not
same with linux and mac software
operating systems
so we need to know how we can secure
these operating systems
similarly all of these would have
desktop versions and server versions
of operating systems as an ethical
hacker we need to know
the desktop and server versions both how
to configure them and how to provide
services within the organization
on these servers so that they can be
consumed in a secure manner by all the
employees
at the same time they should also be
knowledgeable of programming languages
or scripting languages such as php
python
ruby html for programming if you will
because web servers come into the
picture so again
they should not be great developers
where they can
create huge applications but they should
be able to develop scripts
understand those scripts analyze those
scripts and figure out what the output
should be of those scripts to achieve
the
hacking goals that they have set out for
an ethical hacker should have a very
good understanding about networking
no matter whether you're in application
security you're in network security or
you're in host-based security
since a computer will always be
connected to a network either a local
area network like a lan
or the internet we should know how
networking works we should know the
seven layers of the osi model we should
know which protocols work
on those seven layers we should identify
the tcp model and how
osi model can be mapped to the tcp model
we should understand how tcp and udp
work how
how each and every protocol is crafted
how they are supposed to behave
for us to analyze and understand any
network based attacks
we should be very good in security
measures so we should know
where those vulnerabilities would lie
what are the latest exploits available
in the market
and we should be able to identify them
we should be able to know the techniques
and the tools
of how to deal with security how to
analyze security
and then how to implement security to
enhance it as well
along with that it is important that a
security analyst or
ethical hacker is aware of the local
security laws and standards
why is that because an organization
cannot do any illegal activity
whatever responses that they have
whatever security mechanisms whatever
security controls they will implement
they need to be
adhering to the local law of the land
they should be legal in nature
and should not cause undue harm to any
of the employees or any of the
third party clients that they are
dealing with so the ethical hackers
should be aware of what security laws
are
before they implement security controls
or even before they start testing for
security controls
and all of these should be backed up by
having a global
certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical hacking the
law of the land
anything and everything maybe even
programming it's good to have a
certification in php pearl python ruby
and so on so forth why because most of
the organizations when they hire ethical
hackers
look out for these certifications
especially globally valid certifications
so that they can be sure or they can be
assured that the person that they are
hiring
has the required skill set so let's talk
about a few of the tools that an ethical
hacker
would utilize in the testing scenarios
to be honest there are hundreds of tools
out there
what you see on the screen is just a few
examples of them
uh nessus is a vulnerability scanner
what is a vulnerability scanner it is an
automated tool that is designed to
identify vulnerabilities
within hosts within operating systems
within networks
so they come with their ready-made
databases of all the vulnerabilities
that have already been identified
and the scan the network against that
database to find out any possible flaws
or any possible vulnerabilities that
currently exist
on the host or the operating system or
on the network similarly there would be
application scanners
like acunetix or arachne that would help
you scan
applications and identify flaws within
those applications as well
now all of these are automated tools the
essence of ethical hacker is when these
tools churn out the reports the ethical
hacker can understand these reports
analyze them identify the flaws
and then craft their own exploits or use
existing exploits in a
particular manner so that they can get
access
or they can bypass the access or
security controls mechanisms that are
already in place
how can they do that with the tool
called metasploit you see that big
m there on the right hand side that m
logo is for a tool called metasploit
which is a penetration testing tool
what is a penetration testing tool it is
that tool that will allow
a ethical hacker to craft their exploits
or choose their exploits for the
vulnerabilities that have been
identified by nessus
since we are interacting with computers
we will always be interacting using
tools
right so the first tool nessus
identifies the flaws and the possible
list of vulnerabilities we do a
penetration test using metasploit to
validate those flaws
and to verify that those flaws actually
exist
and try to figure out the complexity of
those flaws and that's where metasploit
helps
us do that wireshark would be used in
the background while we are doing both
the activities using nessus or
metasploit
to keep a track of what packets are
being sent and by received on the
network which will help us analyze those
packets
so whenever i run an ss scanner i would
run a wireshark in the background it
will capture the data packets and i can
go through those data packets and
analyze that data package to identify
what nessus is actually trying to do
similarly when i try to attack a machine
using exploit on metasploit i will keep
on
wireshark running in the background to
capture the data package that have been
sent
and the responses that i've received
from the victim so that i can also go
through those packets
and analyze the responses and analyze
the attack whether it was successful
to what extent was it successful and
basically will also give me a validation
of proof
of the activity that has happened nmap
is another automated tool that allows me
to scan for
open ports and protocols so why would i
use
nmap because pro ports and protocols
become an
entry point for a hacker to gain access
to devices
for example when we connect to a web
server we connect through a web browser
but we automatically connect to port 80
using http
and port 443 is using https so if i'm
connecting to a web server
using https it is safe to assume that
port 443
on the web server is open to accept
those connections
similarly there would be other services
that may be left open on the web server
because nobody thought about configuring
it or they misconfigured the web server
and they left unwanted services running
so nmap will allow me to scan those
ports and services
and allow me to understand what services
are being offered on that server
so then i can start analyzing that
server identify those flaws within those
services
and then try to attack them if the
application that i'm analyzing
is connected to a database and i want to
do a sql injection attack or
if i if nessus tells me that there is a
sql injection attack that may be
possible
on that particular application i can use
an automated tool
called sql map or sql map that would
allow me to
automatically craft all the queries that
are required for a sql injection attack
and help me do that attack at the same
time so here i do not have to manually
create
my own queries uh the sql map tool would
automatically create
them for me what i would do is i would
use nessus to identify that particular
flaw
if nessus reports that flaw i would then
go use the tool
sql map configure it to attack that
particular web server
and when i fire off the tool it will
then automatically start
directing queries sql injection queries
to the database to see if those
databases are vulnerable and if yes what
data can be retrieved from those
databases
so all of these tools in a nutshell
would help me
hack networks applications operating
systems and host devices
and this is what an ethical hacker does
they use these kind of tool sets they
identify what attacks they need to do
they identify the right tool for that
particular attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management
providing them feedback about how the
attack was created
or crafted what was the response to that
attack and whether the attack was
successful or not
if successful they would also give
recommendations of what to do to prevent
these attacks
from happening in the future so when we
are doing these
attacks or when we want to launch these
attacks what is the process that
we would follow so there are six steps
that we would do
as an ethical hacker if you are just a
hacker you probably wouldn't do the
sixth step which is a reporting
step so the first step that would be
done is the reconnaissance phase which
is the information gathering phase
which is very important from ethical
hackers perspective or a hacker's
perspective because if i want to attack
someone
or something as a digital device i need
to know what i'm attacking
i need to know the ip address of the
device the mac address of those devices
i need to know the operating system the
build or the version of that operating
systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so i know what i'm
attacking
for example if i if i want to attack a
server i assume it's a windows based
server
and i use a particular tool to attack it
but it actually turns out to be a linux
based server my attacks are going to be
unsuccessful so i need to focus my
attack based on what is
there at the other end so in my
information gathering phase i want to
identify all of that information
once i have that information done i'm
going to scan those servers
using tools like nmap that we just
talked about and we're going to try to
see
the open ports open services and
protocols that are running
on that server that can give me possible
entry points
within the network or within the device
or within the operating system
at the same time along with the scanning
with nmap i would run a
vulnerability scanner the nexus
vulnerability scanner we talked about or
acunetix for applications and then i
would try to
identify vulnerabilities in those
applications operating systems or
networks
once i have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase i
would then move on to the gaining phase
where i would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits
and start attacking the attacking the
victim at this point in time if my
attack is successful i will probably
have gained access
by either tracking passwords or
escalating privileges
or exploiting a vulnerability that i may
have found during the scanning phase
once i have gained my access i want to
maintain my access
why because the vulnerability may not be
there for long maybe somebody updated
the operating system and hence the flaw
was no longer exist
or existing or somebody change the
password that we have i may have cracked
does i no longer have access
so what do i do to maintain my access i
install trojans
or backdoor entries to those systems
using which i can
secretly in a covert manner get access
to those devices
at my own will at my own time as long as
those devices are available over the
network so that's where i maintain my
access
i have hacked them now i want to
maintain my access so i install a
software which would give me a backdoor
entry to that device
no matter what once i have done this i
want to clear my track so whatever
activity that i've been doing
for example installing a trojan a trojan
is also a software that would create
directory directories and files once
installed on the victim's
machine so i want to hide that if i have
access data stores if i have modified
data
i want to hide that activity because if
the victim comes to know that something
has happened
they would start they would start
increasing their security parameters
they might start scanning their devices
they may take them offline thus my hack
would no longer be efficient
the reason i'm clearing my tracks is
that the victim doesn't find out that
they have been hacked or they have been
compromised
or even if they do find out that they've
been compromised they cannot trace the
compromise back to me
so i would be deleting references of any
of the ip addresses or mac addresses
that i may have used to attack that
particular device
and this is where i will be able to
identify where those logs were created
where those traces are once i take off
those traces the victim
would not be any wiser of whether they
have been compromised
or who compromised their system and if i
am successful at all of these stages
or what to whatever extent the success
that i've achieved in any of these
stages
i would then create a report based on
that and i would report
to the management about the activities
that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we identified 10 different flaws
there were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do
what attack did we do what was the
outcome of that attack
what was the intended or or the expected
output of that attack
i'll create a report which would give a
detailed analysis of all the steps that
were taken along with screenshots and
evidences of what activity was conducted
what was the output what was the
expected output and i would submit that
report to the management
giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated
so that the security can be enhanced so
these are the six steps that the ethical
hacking
process would take uh just going through
this the uh recognizance is where you're
going to use hacking tools like nmap hp
to obtain information about targets
there are hundreds of tools out there
depending on what information you want
then in scanning again nmap
nexpose these kind of tools to be
utilized to identify open ports
protocols and services
in gaining access you're going to
exploit the vulnerability by using the
metasploit tool that we talked about in
the previous slides
in the maintaining access you're going
to install back doors
you can use meta squad at the same time
you can craft your own scripts to create
a trojan and install it on the victims
machine
once you have achieved that clearing
tracks is where you're going to clear
all evidences
of your activity so that you do not get
caught or the victim doesn't even
realize that they have been hacked
and once you have done all of this we
are going to create reports
that are going to be submitted to the
management to help them understand
the current security evaluation of their
organization
so now let's see how we can hack using
social engineering now what is social
engineering
social engineering is the art of
manipulating humans
into revealing confidential information
which they otherwise would not have
revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you are able to communicate
effectively to another person
they would probably give up more
information that they intended to give
out
let's take a look at examples right if
you see on the screen
fishing activity what is fishing we
receive a lot of freak meals on a
regular basis
we have always received those emails
where we have won a lottery of a few
million dollars
but we have never realized that we
didn't purchase a lottery to win a
lottery in the first place we have
always had those
nigerian frauds where a prince died in
some south african country and you
out of seven billion people on the
planet have been identified
where they want to transfer a few
hundred million dollars through your
account
and they want to give you fifty 50 of
that money in return as thank you
so some very basic attacks where you go
on to websites
and there's a banner flashing at you
saying congratulations you're the 1
millionth
visitor to this website click here to
claim your price
all of these a social engineering
attacks phishing attacks
fake websites fake communications being
sent out
to users to prey on their gullibility
most of humans
always have that dream of striking it
rich winning a huge lottery once and for
all and living their life lavishly ever
after
but sadly in the real world that's not
that doesn't happen that often
and if you're receiving those males it
is very important that you first
research the validity of those those
communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotions
machines do not try pleading with a
machine to give you access to a
account that you have forgotten a
password to the machine wouldn't even
know what you're doing try pleading with
a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social injury attack where
you can
plead with them saying if i do not get
access to this account immediately i
might lose my job
and then that would put my family into
problems somebody would feel empathy or
sympathy towards you
and help you reset that password and
give you access to that account
it's how good the attack is and how
convincing you
are for the success of this attack to
happen so what is a familiarity exploit
attackers interact with victims to gain
information
which will benefit the attackers to
crack credentials as
passwords if we want to reset our
passwords what do we have
as a mechanism to resetting passwords we
have some security questions that we set
up those questions are nothing but
personal information that we would know
but through a social engineering attack
it would be easily be able to uh gather
the information that you have set
for your security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
school that you attended you probably
have that listed on your linkedin
profile
where a person can just go in there and
see your academic qualifications
and identify the school that you're in
right similarly
it might also be a question what was
your mother's maiden name that's a very
good attack
and that's uh i mean if a person can
interact with you
let's say they are trying to take a
survey and they approach you for a
feedback on a particular product that
you have been utilizing
and they ask you these questions you
wouldn't think twice before giving those
answers
as long as the request sounds legitimate
to us we are able to justify that
request
we do answer those queries so it's upon
us to verify the authenticity
of the request coming in before we
answer it
phishing as discussed would be
fraudulent emails which appear to be
coming from a trusted source
so email spoofing comes into mind uh
fake websites
and so on so forth exploiting human
curiosity curiosity killed the cat right
so there was
uh there's so many physical attacks
where hackers just keep
pen drives lying around in a parking lot
now this is open a generic attack
whoever falls victim will fall victim so
if i just
throw around a few usbs in the parking
lot obviously with trojans implemented
on them
some people who are curious or who are
looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives
at the same time once they plug in those
pendrives on their computers the virus
or the trojan would get infected and
cause harm to their machine
then exploiting human greed we just
talked about the
nigerian frauds and the lotteries those
kind of attacks
the fake money making gimmicks now
basically this is where you
prey upon the person's greed kicking in
and they are clicking on those links in
order to get that money that has been
promised to them in that email
so one of the safest mechanism to keep
data private and to keep yourself secure
is using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography
cryptography is the art of scrambling
data
using a particular algorithm so that the
data becomes unreadable
to the normal user the only person with
the key to unscramble that data would be
able to unscramble it and make sense out
of that data so we're just
making it unreadable or non-readable by
using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we're
going to send the key to the
end user the you end user using the same
key
would then decrypt that data if anybody
compromises that data while it is being
sent over the network since it is
encrypted
they would not be able to read it so the
encryption algorithm would be something
like this now if you see
uh the computer word once made into
unreadable format would
look like e q o r x v gt
for an end user it wouldn't make any
sense but the person who has a key
to unscramble that would be able to
convert it back to computer
and then understand the meaning of that
word so this is just a substitution
cipher that is being shown on the screen
so what is the alphabet the key is
alphabet plus three
so c plus three alphabets that becomes e
o
becomes q m becomes o so the
key that is utilized to scramble the
data is
the character that you are at the third
character from there
would be the corresponding key so the
encrypted message is also known as a
cipher the decryption is just the other
way around where you know the key now
and you can now figure out what that e
corresponding to
by going back three characters in the
alphabet
most of the times a certified ethical
hacker must decrypt a message without
knowing the secret key
so let's say a ransomware has affected
your organization
or has affected a device and you want to
figure out
uh or you want to decrypt that data now
as an ethical hacker you wouldn't be
for paying a ransom to the hacker would
you so it is now your prerogative of how
you're going to work around and how
you're going to
try to crack the encryption mechanism
how to crack the cipher to
decrypt that message and see what's
within it right decryption without the
use of a secret key that is known as a
cryptanalysis
cryptanalysis is the reversing of an
algorithm to figure out
what the decryption was without using a
key so cryptanalysis can be done using
various formats the first one is a brute
force attack second is a dictionary
attack the third one is a rainbow table
attack a brute force attack is trying
every combination permutation and
combination
of the key to figure out what the key
was it is 100 successful
but may take a lot of time a dictionary
attack is where you have created a list
of possible
encryption mechanisms a list of possible
cracks and then you try to figure out
whether those cracks
work or not rainbow tables are where you
have an encrypted text
in hand and you're trying to figure out
uh the similarities between between the
text that you have
and the encrypted data that you wanted
to decrypt in the first place
so in the brute force attack you're
trying every possible combination
permutation
of what the key would be in dictionary
attack you have a word list that would
tantamount to the key and if you're
you're trying to match
all the words listed in the text file or
the word list to see if any of those
words are going to work
to decrypt that data here in the rainbow
table the cipher text is compared with
another cipher text you find out
similarities
and then you try to work a reverse
engineer your way accordingly so let's
have a quick demo on cryptography
before we begin this session so to begin
with the demo of cryptography
we are on our website called spammic.com
which will help us
scramble the message that we created
into a completely uh
format which would be unrelated to the
topic at hand
so if i say i want to encode a message i
turn a short message into spam so what
this does is
you want to send across a secret message
you type in the secret message
a short one it will convert that into a
spam mail
you send it across so whoever's reading
that spam mail would never get an idea
of the embedded message within it
so if i want to type in a message here
hi this is a secret message
the password is asd at the rate one two
three four
and i want to send this out to people or
to one of my colleagues but i want to
send it out in a secret manner so that
others
are not aware of this so when i press on
encode what the algorithm will do is it
will convert this message
into a spam mail so my message hi this
is a secret message the password is at
the rate one two three four
or asd at the rate one two three four
gets converted into this
now if you read it dear e-commerce
professional this letter was specially
selected to be sent to you
this doesn't make sense there is nowhere
or no reference
to the actual message that i've already
said so if
i copy this entire message and i send it
let's say via
email to the recipient now the thing is
that the recipient needs to know that
i've encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm remain needs to remain the
same
so once they know that it is spam mimic
what they can do is now in this instance
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
open up a new browser
and i'm going to go to the same website
and at this point in time
i'm going to click on decode when i
click on decode
i'm going to paste the message that i
have just copied
there we are and this message is now
being copied into a different browser
and if i decode this you will see that
it will convert it back to the original
message that there was
so the key is there at spam mimic and
it is embedded within the message so
whenever we paste the message in the
decode factor
it knows what the key was and it can
decrypt that message
and give me the actual message that was
embedded within it
there we are the entire message this is
what we created
in the google chrome browser and in the
firefox browser we decoded
similarly if i want to protect these
kind of messages there is an aspen
encrypt.com website where let's say we
use
text encryption and i want to encrypt
the same message
this is a secret message
the password is asd at the rate one two
three four
and then i give it a password to protect
this message let's say the word password
and i use the cipher to scramble this by
using let's say aes which is the
strongest cipher right now
and i say encrypt so this is what the
encryption would look like
and basically uh if i don't have the
password over here if i decrypt it
you would see that the error has
occurred if i type in the password over
here and then decrypt it it will be able
to convert that back
into the unscrambled text and it will
give me what the original
message was this is a secret message the
password is asd at the rate one two
three four
so if i want to keep my data secure from
hackers
i want to scramble it in such a way that
they would not be able to crack it or it
would be very difficult
for them to crack it and this is one of
the first mechanisms
that would be recommended by any ethical
hacker to keep the data secure
now let's talk about downloading and
installing kali linux along with that
we'll also be looking at the basic
commands that are required for kali
linux
all right so i've opened my browser and
we want to go to the kali website so we
want to go to kali.org
you can directly type in kali.org and go
to the website i can just do a google
search
and say kali download and it will give
you the same website but it will
directly take you to the downloads pages
so either here and or you can go to the
home page
cookies are being installed on your
machine so see which cookies you want to
allow i'm only going to use the
necessary cookies
to support the site and you can see that
this gives you the latest kali linux
news and tutorials gives you the latest
release what is in that release and
gives you a lot of documentation which
will help you understand what tools
have been developed and what
functionality has been given in the
latest version
if you want to download you can directly
go here and you can
download kali linux now kali linux is a
2.6 gigabyte download so it's going to
take time the latest version being 2019
and we click over here i'm using a
download manager to manage all these
huge downloads
and you can see it's pointed to the
operating systems folder
and it is going to be a 2.57 gb
download so we click on download and in
the background
you can see this is going to be
downloaded and you're going to minimize
this
and uh it will take a few minutes for
that to download but this is an iso
image so we need to install it on a
virtual machine
so what we need is we need to use a
hypervisor which will allow us to create
virtual machines so we can either use
vmware workstation
which you can download from here however
uh this is
paid version so you can see it is around
250
or something for uh this software but it
is a very good software to have so if
you click on download now
it is going to start the download it's a
30-day trial period
if you want to use it after 30 days
you'll need to enter the key
which you'll get after purchasing the
software if you do not want to utilize
this
the free version that you have you can
either download
vmware player but there are some
limitations for vmware player that you
might want to look at
does you want to compare these products
before you want to purchase them
right otherwise you can download oracle
virtualbox
which is a free hypervisor it's not as
robust as vmware workstation
but it does the trick right so the the
free version
6.1 is free and you can then create your
own
virtual machines over there and install
operating systems
on them what i do have i already have a
vmware workstation installed so i'm just
going to open that up
and that's my vmware workstation as you
can see i already have a lot of virtual
machines created over here
what we're going to do is we're going to
configure a virtual machine for the kali
linux
operating system that we are downloading
which should be somewhere here
let's see it's at 43 percent so
halfway there till then let's create the
virtual machine so i click click on file
create a new virtual machine i'm going
to customize the
machine so click on next this little
default we don't want to change that
and then we want to install the
operating system later we don't want to
point it out right now so
i'll just click on i will install the
operating system later click on next
we want to install linux now in the drop
down you would not see
kali linux over here however you can
choose
ubuntu 64-bit that's what i'm going to
choose
there it is next what is the name that
we want
i want to give it kali linux without the
typo
and i want to store it in one of the
folders that i created
by default it stores on the c drive
which is not a good place to store
uh you don't want to run out of space on
your c drive so i'm going to click on
this pc
and this is my data and in here i'll
have a folder called virtualbox
or virtual machines there it is within
which you can see the other softwares
that i already created
i'm going to need to create a new folder
and call it kali 2019
l l for it is latest for me because you
can see already have a kali linux so i'm
just going to
identify this folder with the l at the
end going to
select it and click on okay you can see
the path being changed over here
click on next it's going to ask you how
many processors now depending on the
processor that you have
you can see i've got a 8 core i7 so if i
give it 16 cores or 16 processors that's
not going to work
i cannot go beyond what the physicality
already is
so for this machine one processor with
one core is more than enough
if you're going to load use a lot of
tools at the same time you might just
want to give it two cores
so we've given it two cores it will ask
us
for ram to be provided for this virtual
machine by default 2048 megabytes that's
2gb of ram is more than enough
if you require more we can change this
later on so click on next
we want to use nat for now leave this
default next
whatever is recommended keep it the way
it is we do not want to change it
next create a new virtual hard disk for
this machine
and it is going to ask us the size 20 gb
is more than fine store it as a single
file
we don't want to use multiple file
options click on next
and then click on browse wherever you
want to store the vmdk file
or the virtual hard disk file and we go
back again to the same folder that we
had created
virtual machines and we look at the
kali linux kali 2019 l and we want to
store the
vmdk file over there once we save it we
want to click on next
and then we want to click on finish so
this is the virtual machine that has
been created right here
right now this is the basic
configuration now where are we at with
the operating system
and you can see the operating uh system
has been downloaded and it is
stored in this particular folder so we
go to e drive
so we are looking for the sub the
operating system that we have downloaded
we downloaded in the
operating systems folder and if we go in
here you can see the
current one the kali linux 2019.4
iso right here so what we do we go back
to the kali linux machine that we have
created
edit virtual machine settings and we
point this virtual machine
using the cd dvd and then we point the
iso
the one that we downloaded over here so
we go back to e drive we go back to os
and we click on kali linux 2019 click on
open
so now when this boots up it will boot
up with this iso and then
it will allow us to install the
operating system so click on ok
then we click on power on this virtual
machine it will start powering on
it will boot to the eye so it will start
giving us the booting
options so i'm just going to enter the
full screen mode over here
for this to be better visible and we
don't want the live mode what we want is
we want to use the graphical install
and then we highlight that we press
enter and you can see the setup starting
up
we'll wait for the gui to pop up there
it is which language do we want for now
we want english
click on continue where are we located
click on continue
and the configure your keyboard we
want the us keyboard american english
continue it is going to detect the
hardware so as you can see on the screen
it's attempting a
auto configuration for most of these uh
settings the network with dhcp it has
identified
the network cards uh hardware like the
processor
that has been provided but it's asking
for a host name we're going to leave it
at default
we're going to click on continue domain
name i'm not
joining this into a domain as yet
there's going to be a standalone machine
so i can leave this blank
click on continue now it is going to
configure the network it is asking for a
password
at this point in time the root password
type in any password that you want
ensure that you remember the password
now by default the
username for the account is the name is
the word root we are just creating the
password for the root account
and then we want to click on continue
setting up the clock looking at the hard
disks
now here it asks us do we want to use
the entire disk the 20gb virtual hard
disk that we had provided or do we want
to give it a manual
configuration or a guided one where we
want encryption
and a logical volume management coming
into the picture we're just going to use
the first option guided you
use entire disk don't worry it's only
going to use the virtual disk that we
had created
click on continue it will give us that
it's a 21.5 gb
vmware virtual disk that we had and
click on continue all files in one
partition that's what we want
recommended for new users whatever it is
we don't want to change these folders
continue and this is what we have
configured uh once we click on continue
it is going to say
you are you sure you want to make these
changes click on yes
click on continue and it will start
installing kali linux on your
device now this is going to take a few
minutes for the installation to work
all right so that's the installation
that's completed now it's asking us to
configure a package manager a network
mirror can be used to supplement the
software
that is included on the installation
media this may also make new versions of
software available you want to use a
network mirror we can click
no for now and then click on continue
now this is going to install the grub
bootloader this might take a few minutes
as well install the group
grub loader to the master boot record
yes click on
continue click the hard disk that you
have just utilized
this is the one click on continue it
will install the grub boot loader
running through the last
phases of the installation and now it
says the installation is complete we
want to click click on continue
finishing the installation and then it
will do a reboot
all right and you can see this is
starting up so we are going to use you
just wait out
the boot and now it started the booting
sequence
just going to maximize the screen and
you can see it's asking me for the
password this is the one that we created
now
that's the that's not the password
that's the username that's the root
and the password that we had created at
that point in time
and then click on log in and this is
your screen
and now what we need to do here is we
need to install
vmware tools which will help us manage
the screen
and help the virtual machine to be a
little bit better
uh integrated on the system so that's
not mounted yet so we're just waiting
for it to mount there it is
and what we want to do here is
open vmware tools upgrader all right so
what we want is we want to
extract or we want to use this open x
archiver
and once we do that we'll see the vmware
install dot pl double click on that
all right we've got the vmware tools
here what i've done is we have
extract2 and i've extracted that on the
desktop
right so what we just did was click on
the desktop over here
open and this is what it will do and
click on extract
now there is happening because i've
already extracted this open this up we
want to run
this vmware install dot pl so what do we
do we open up the terminal window
which is the command line interface over
here and now this is where some of the
commands come into the picture
so for example pwd will show us the
present working directory
ls will show us the list of the folders
that are there so
the folder that we have is on our
desktop so we'll just change directory
to desktop press enter do an ls that
will show us the list and you can see
vmware tools this trip that's
the folder that we have right here right
so we want to go into that folder
see the vmware at this point you can
just click on tab and it will populate
everything over there
press enter do an ls and we want the
vmware
hyphen install dot pl to be executed
all right so we tried executing that
command we had an error over there
so what we need to do is we need to
execute this command so dot slash
vmware and hyphen install.pl and we'll
start creating now
uh it will ask you for your input
installing vmware tools in which
directory do you want to install the
binary files uh by default it is going
to
use slash usr slash bin if i just press
enter it is going to use the default as
you can see the input over here
what directory do you want the init
directories i'm just going to press
keep on pressing enter for the defaults
to come in this part does not exist
it is going to create it default yes
defaults
everywhere and then it tries to start
initializing it
to maximize the screen and this is where
it is installing
and you can see by just installing that
it automatically adjusted the screen
and now we got a full screen of kali
linux right here right and that is what
vmware tools does for us once we have
installed the
operating system and now you can see the
entire screen on here
you will see the tool sets that are
given here now why are we using kali
linux in the first place because this
comes in
uh with a bundle of thousands of
softwares that are ready to be utilized
for ethical hacking
right and they have been categorized
over here for information gathering
vulnerability analysis web application
analysis and so on so forth so you can
see from forensics onwards
reporting tools and as you scroll down
you can see your development tools
graphics coming in internet
and the system configuration coming into
the picture these
are your settings for your operating
system so these are basically your tools
we are right now the favorites if i
click on information gathering you will
see that
other tools for information gathering
start appearing over here
for vulnerability analysis we have got
sparta in map fuzzing tools web
application analysis we have got comics
skip fish
sql map database assessments password
attacks and so on so forth so if we just
go in the favorites
this was the terminal emulator that we
utilized is the command line that we saw
we use the cd command
we use the pwd command we did the ls
command as well to give us the list
of the directory that we are in
similarly there would be
commands like cat so let's go to cd
downloads let's see what the
uh what's there they can see this case
sensitive so if i type in a capital d
and then do a tab ls there's nothing
over here
on download so cd dot dot will take us
back one directory i can see we are back
from
downloads to root if i want to go to
desktop
this is how i go to desktop do a ls you
can see the vmware tools
uh folder over there cd vmware tools and
we go into that folder ls will give us
the list of all those files now you can
see install is a file that we had
edited back then so if i do a cat
install
you will see the cat basically is the
command that will help us look at the
contents of the file all right without
opening up the file without editing the
file so you can see just
uh if i scroll up this is where we give
the cat command it then
uh printed the contents of the file over
here and then it exited and gave me back
to
command line right here right now if i
want to copy this
cp root desktop vmware
install and if you want to copy it to
root
downloads and press enter now what we
are going to do is we are going to see
if this file the install file that we
just edited over here
has been copied to the downloads folder
so we do us
we are currently in the vmware on the
desktop vmware tools district folder
video cd dot dot
that takes us down one directory so we
are still in the desktop do a cd dot dot
now you can see we are back in the root
and now we are going to
do a cd downloads to an ls and you can
see the
copied file right here so if i do a cat
install
you can see the same content of that
file coming in so these are some of the
commands that we would need to learn as
we go ahead
the remove command is let's say we've
got
install we do a man rm man is the manual
page command
that gives us the pages with the
description of how that particular
command is to be utilized so rm is
remove files or directories
synopsis is the description the options
hyphen f4 hyphen i for prompt hyphen
capitalize prompt once
before removing more than three files
and so on so forth
if you want to exit this you can press q
to exit
and you come back to this page so if i
say rm
install ls you will see that the install
file has now been deleted so in windows
we use the del del command
in linux it is the rm command so this is
what we wanted to look at
the demo for kali linux how to download
it how to install it and some of the
basic commands that we can utilize
all right let's begin with the phishing
tutorial
we have the kali linux operating system
booted up over here uh what we are going
to do is we are going to open up a tool
called set social engineering toolkit
which you would find in this option
and that's the tool that we want it's a
command line tool a menu driven tool
we are going to host a fake facebook
page and we can see how we can
harvest credentials by this kind of an
attack so
these are some disclaimers you might
want to go through that do you want to
agree to the terms of
service yes press enter
and that's your social engineering
toolkit and we
are talking about a phishing attack
which can comes under the social
engineering attack so it like i said
it's a menu driven tool
so we just have to look at these options
and then just type in the
number of the option that we want so we
want to do a social engineering attack
so i type in one
press enter in that it is asking me
whether i want a spear phishing attack
a website attack vector we are going to
choose a second option so i type in two
press enter and then it asks me uh
what i want to do i want to take the
third option here credential harvester
attack methodology
and we want to do the third attack now
it is asking whether we want to use the
in-house
website templates that it already has or
do we want to clone a site
or do we have a customized site that we
have prepared that we want to migrate
into this tool
we're going to do the site cloning
option so we're going to type in two
press enter and then it is going to ask
me the ip address where it wants to
capture
and store the credentials by default
this is the ip address that i'm using so
if i leave it blank it will take my
default ip address so i'm just going to
press
enter and now it is asking me the url
to clone so i type in https
www.facebook.com what it is going to do
it is going to connect online
and it is now just it has cloned the
website
uh facebook login.php the best way to
use this attack is that you if use the
if the username and password form are in
the same field
or the same page regardless this
captures all posts on a website
so you may need to copy www.star into
html depending on where your directory
structure is press return if you
understand
what we are seeing here so press enter
the social engineering toolkit
credential harvest attack is running on
port 80 information will be displayed to
you as it arrives so the site was 71.134
right the default ip address and this is
where the website is being hosted
let's check that out so let me open up a
browser on my host machine
and let me point it to the kali linux
machine that we have just created
192.168.71.134
and you should see a login to facebook
coming up right here looks genuine it is
genuine because we
just went online and downloaded this
let's just have a recap
let's have a explanation of what we are
trying to do i am trying to host
fake facebook page on my server which
has an embedded script in it which is
going to do credential harvesting
so the attack here is let's say if i
have now hosted this i can
craft a fake email send it across to a
victim
saying uh your facebook account has seen
some unforeseen activity
create a hyperlink using html coding
within that click here to access your
account and verify
uh that the account is secured and when
they click on that link they will be
redirected to
my fake page which is here you can see
the ip address is my virtual machine's
ip address but i'm seeing a facebook
login page and i'm going to type in
someone at
somewhere.com and the password i'm just
going to type in
the regular ones that i use and if you
see it
when we typed in uh the username and
password the page just refreshed and
gave us the login page again but now if
you look at the url i'm actually on
facebook's login page which is exactly
the same that i was hosting
so a layman wouldn't probably figure out
they've been hacked by now they just
would figure out okay they probably
typed in the incorrect password and the
page refresh or something like that
and they're just going to log in and
they're actually going to access the
facebook page
thus they might not even realize that
something went wrong
but if i go back to my virtual machine
you can see that it has captured some
data and it is reporting over here
of what has happened so if i just scroll
up let's see what happened here and if
you have been able to
capture anything so we gotta hit
printing the output this does the http
1.1
200 okay response coming in password
field
phone and we just looking
there it is email someone at
somewhere.com
and uh password that i typed in asd at
the rate one two three
four so it has captured the username and
the password right here
uh once you're done i mean this is the
way attackers work now this is a very
basic attack
again uh in the actual trainings you
would then look at how you would host
this
on a real website make it a global
attack right now it's a
virtual machine with a class cip address
so
here the thought process is where can we
get a free hosting
where we can host this kind of sites
maybe i'll have to purchase a domain
which looks like similar to facebook or
the victim that i'm trying to attack so
this is just a poc
so we just wanted to find out if we can
uh how phishing is done and this is
exactly how it is done
right so pressing ctrl c would exit this
tool
and takes you back to the actual menu
press 99.99 to exit and
there it is close the two window and
that's
the phishing practical after phishing
let's talk about
sql injection sql injection stands for
uh
structured query language injection
which is a database attack
though it resides within the application
so it's the application vulnerability
that we are trying to
look at to try to bypass authentication
as the name suggests a sequel injection
vulnerability allows an attacker to
inject malicious input into a sql
statement what is a sql statement
a query that is used by an application
and is fired off to the database
database executes that query uh gets
that uh information that is required
and sends it back to the user if the
user is authenticated so we're going to
look at the sql injection attack demo
here
and uh what we are going to do is we are
going to go back to our vmware
workstation
and i have got a tool over here called
ovasp broken web application which is a
utility that has been created for people
like us to
test our skills to learn on how we can
develop our skills
further so this has a lot of vulnerable
applications built within it we're just
going to try to access it
and we are going to see if we can create
a sql injection attack
just waiting for it to boot up once it
boots up it will give us an ip address
there we are so we need to connect to
71.132
so i can just use the same browser i was
using
close up facebook and now go to
192.168.71.132
and this is the ovap broken web
application project uh what we are going
to do is we are going to go to utility
and this is a application that has a lot
of information within it you can see it
gives you links about what you should do
help me video tutorials listing of
vulnerabilities that they have and so on
so forth so you can see we are not
logged in right now
i'm just going to do this as a demo so
what we're going to do is we're going to
look at this
and bypass authentication so we are
taken to the login page where you need a
username and password to log
in i'm going to type in test as the
username and
test as the password click on login and
you can see that account does not exist
so the authentication mechanism works
now what we want to do is we want to
create a query
now what does a query look like when i
type in a username and a password if i
just type in a single quote here
it is going to create an error and this
is what the sql query looks like
select username from accounts where
username is a single quote and then the
exception error happened so it's not
showing the rest of the query to us
now what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to craft a query here
uh single quote and give it a condition
or
one equals one space hyphen hyphen space
what happens hyphen hyphen space is
comments out anything after that so the
password field is being commented out at
this point in time and i'm just giving
it a condition where the condition is
true one does equal
one and if this condition is true it is
going to allow me to log
in so you can see right now we are not
logged in this bypasses the
authentication mechanism and you can see
user authenticated and we are now logged
in as admin
so uh in the training what we need to
understand uh as a whole is how sql
works what are the queries that are
structured with how you can
what are the testing operators now the
single quote that we used that was an
operator in the sql syntax what these
operators are
how they function and then how you can
leverage these attacks
there are different tools that are given
to you in kali
as well that you can utilize so in kali
linux
you can just open up a command prompt
and there's a tool called sql map
you need to give it a particular site so
sql
map hyphen u for the url and whatever
the url
is now url here and then once you're
here you just
press the enter key this tool will craft
all the queries in the background for
you you don't even have to no sql query
or
sql languages uh this is a very easy
tool to utilize
sadly i cannot demo this on a live
website because that would be illegal
but
you can see how you can operate this
yourself
that's what sql injections are all about
moving on
we now talk about uh vpn's virtual
private networks
and a virtual private network is
basically a secure network that allows
me to anonymize myself over the
internet so what i'm doing is i'm
connecting from here to a server
that encrypts my channel encrypts my
connection and does allows me to
keep my data secure now the basic
essence of a vpn or a virtual private
network
is to allow me this encryption mechanism
where i can
encrypt and safeguard my data the added
advantage that nowadays a vpn gives
is that you can allow us to spoof our ip
address or
obfuscate our ip address so we can
actually become anonymous on the
internet it can allow us to
use multiple ip addresses and thus
secure ourselves on the internet for
example
i use vpn called cyberghost and what
this allows me to do
is it allows me so many servers over
here
and if you look at the entire list all
the servers then there are no spy
servers
which and guarantee me that they are not
going to keep and store any
logs and thus they are not going to
record any of the activity that i'm
doing
right since they are located out of
romania this becomes a little bit more
safer for me because the government and
the laws over there are a little bit
more relaxed than other countries
uh they give me different links for
torrenting for streaming for connection
features so
there are a lot of vpns out there so for
example let's
go to the website cyberghost.com so
you can see there's a sale going on 76
percent sale
or you can go on to express vpn
which is also very good vp and then
there is not vpn
it depends on what you want and how you
want to utilize it so
just purchasing a vpn or getting a free
free vpn is not enough it depends
on which country the vpn originates from
and which
server you're connected to for example
most of the
countries have a pact where they share
information amongst themselves even if
you're connected to a vpn that means
that these companies that provide these
services have to generate and store logs
and these logs have to be reported to
the government if they ask for it
now if there's a list of 14 countries
that actually uh
focuses on this practice so you have to
find out vpn that and a server that is
not a part of those 14 countries
and ensure that those logs are not going
to be
reported to the government and these are
three vpns basically are something that
which are good and i personally use
cyberghost i have used others
i just keep on rotating them just to get
an idea of which one is
better so these are vpns that can allow
you to
anonymize yourself on the internet
moving on uh these are the ones that we
talked about there are other safer vpn
hide my ass
expressvpn and so on so forth from our
terminologies let's now talk about vps
uh vps is basically virtual private
server where you can rent a service or
server as a service
a virtual machine as a service so
basically on a cloud using
infrastructure as a service you can rent
a server and utilize it for whatever
activity you want
so let's go to uh these sites
register.com
good id network solutions or we can talk
about other cloud solutions as well
so here you can get register your domain
names
uh so in the previous exercise for let's
say when we talked about
the phishing exercise uh what we want is
we can
go on to register.com or we can go on to
godaddy.com
and we can purchase a particular domain
for example
something like this instead of the os
i'm typing in a couple of zeros
for the facebook and see let's see if
anything of that is available
now something dot photo is available or
facetips.com is available uh there are
other options that are making over here
that they're giving us over here
and once we purchase this we can then
have our own hosting
with a web hosting as a service and uh
you can have a linux based hosting or
a windows-based hosting depending on
what you want and that's where your
shared hosting comes with the picture
if you just want uh if you want to look
at a virtual server
and you want to render server over there
itself you can move on to rackspace.com
and here in your services you can have
physical server or a virtual server in
public cloud
your other cloud providers for example
would be amazon aws
and on aws you can basically look at ec2
elastic compute cloud which is basically
virtual servers in the cloud
and over here you can rent out a server
with whatever capacity you require
you'll obviously have to pay rent for
what those servers are going to cost
but once you have those servers you can
then launch any services
on top of it looking at other services
that we have
we talked about tar tor is a onion
routing uh software that allows users to
browse the web anonymously so we can
just go online and we can try to spoof
our identity and i'm going to show you
how
so i've got a vmware workstation right
here the one so we're just going to pull
that up and we're going to power on a
windows 7 machine
where we're going to look at the onion
routing so windows machine has booted up
we're just going to log
in and uh this is my windows 7 machine
now i've got a
chrome browser right here and we're
going to go to a website called
cmyip.com which is going to give
the ip address that i'm currently using
so right now i'm not on connected to any
vpn or anything and you can see that's
my ip address that i'm utilizing
now if i want to anonymize myself what
i'm going to do is
i am going to use star and that's the
top
browser that's set up right there if i
click on it it's going to open up
the software and it's going to create a
new network and it's going to connect to
the tor network and allow me to
anonymize myself
right so that's the third browser
opening up and
uh giving me a new browser over here so
i've got
one which is the old one which is uh my
current ip address
if i just refresh that you'll see that
i'm still on the same ip address as far
as this browser is concerned
there's a refresh and it's still showing
me the same ip address where if i go on
to thor right now and if i go to see
my ip.com you will see that it is going
to give me
and you can see the amount of time it is
taking to reach that site that's because
i am using
a vpn and there's a lot of encryption
running off and you can see now i'm
certainly
connected via hong kong and even to
reach this site what tor does is it
gives me a
proxy chain a proxy chain is where it
creates multiple hops
to hide my identity and uh before i
reach see my
ip.com i am using three different ip
addresses over here one in france one in
germany and one in hong kong so if i do
something over here
to trace back my steps to my actual ip
address the law enforcement agencies or
anyone who is going to
search like a forensic investigator
would have to go through these ip
addresses before they come back to me
now it's not impossible but the effort
and time that's going to be taken to
come across three different countries
is going to be phenomenal so it may just
defeat the purpose
of having so much resources spent to
identify who did what
so that's what torque does for us all
right moving on from tor we are going to
look at keyloggers
keyloggers are basically softwares that
run in the background and record all the
keystrokes
of the user so if i've got a keylogger
installed right now
whatever i type will be stored in a text
file for the hacker
so that they can look at it later on and
just to give you an example of that we
go back to my vmware workstation and we
open up another windows 7 machine
i'm going to power this on and i'm going
to close this one to them
so this virtual machine has booted up we
are going to use
user one login as user one just close
all these softwares
which are not required and once this
machine is booted up what we're going to
do is i'm just going to open up a random
websites and see what we're doing
basically there's a key logger that's
there in the
startup that's going to record our
keystrokes
and we just want to see what it actually
does now firefox is getting updated so
let's hold on now this is the latest
version of firefox right
and we're just going to go to let's say
facebook.com
wait for the website to open up all
right let's try opening it up again
and that's facebook.com and we're just
going to type in some random username
and password
somewhere someone at somewhere.com and
the password being again
asd at the rate one two three four five
six seven eight nine
zero log in obviously that login is not
going to work user probably doesn't
exist
or if it does the password probably is
kind of incorrect and
uh so we're going to close this
we're going to let's say open up another
browser window go to another site
rediff.com and then go to red if mail
try the same thing over here someone at
somewhere.com
password astrid one two three four five
six seven whatever it is
don't say we can see the combination is
incorrect now there's a
keylogger running in the background and
what we want is we now want to open up
the keylogger now it is visible here
because i've kept it visible
you can hide it in the start menu and
there's a shortcut key for you to pull
it up later on
so this completely becomes invisible and
what it can do is it basically creates a
record of whatever
you have been doing so far so you can
see these things populating on the 25th
of december so if i look at the visited
website you can see i
opened up mozilla firefox the first
where it uh there was a problem loading
the page then you opened up facebook
then we opened up radiifmail.com and so
on and so forth said this
it just gives me the list of visited
websites whereas
if i look at keystrokes and clipboard
you will see whatever we have typed in
so we first typed in facebook.com then
again uh the second time i
try try to type in then i hit backspace
then i type in facebook.com
and then you can see i typed in someone
at somewhere.com and then tab asd at the
rate one two three four five six seven
eight nine zero
we closed up the browser we opened up a
new one and we went on to rediffmail.com
and then you can see me typing this one
then going back
one space then the rest of what i typed
and then the password coming in so
that's what a keylogger does
if you look at the taskbar it's not
going to show you a keylogger running in
the background it's in processes you're
not going to see anything at all
but it's going to mask itself as a
service
so if you look into the properties you
can see that icon coming in over here
which matches this one and so you can
see that this is masking itself as a
service dot exe
if this gets hidden as well it would be
very
difficult for a user to even identify
this all right so that's what a key
logger is
moving on let's see what else we want to
talk about so we've talked about tar we
have talked about key loggers
and now we want to talk about firewalls
now for keyloggers to be prevented we
need antiviruses right so we
need a good antivirus program that's
going to be installed updated
and run on a regular basis to protect
ourselves from malwares
but what about network connections and
you need a firewall and a system
to prevent or to detect what kind of
connections are going on in the first
place
now we cannot rely on software's 100 so
even if a firewall is not configured
properly that's that's going to be a
problem so what we need to do is we have
to have a firewall configure it
correctly
and then allow and disallow certain
activity from off
uh happening and what we're going to do
is i've got such a system
on my machine here i use a software
called glasswire
what it does is it is a network analyzer
so it allows me to analyze whatever is
going on you can see all the apps that
i'm utilizing
and how much upload and download they
have been doing
all the traffic so you can see the
protocols that i'm utilizing
so i come to know what's going on in the
background and this gives me the entire
graph of how much i have been doing for
the past 24 hours past three hours
past five minutes and so on so forth
right so this is what the activities and
these are the alerts that it has been
generating
i can click on those alert and it will
start telling me what it was all about
if the graph doesn't work for me it
gives me usage as well
so how much i have utilized since i've
installed this software
right and what applications have been
utilized which hosts have been connected
to and the traffic type that was
utilized
and then the things on my network so
these are the devices that i have
currently on my network that has been
that have been identified and then comes
the firewall so on the firewall
the firewall is clicked on you see all
those services that have been identified
and you can just click on a particular
service to lock that service
so this becomes a discovery tool
identifies whatever networking is going
on
gives me all that information and then i
can look at and i can just click on any
of these
services that i find it as malicious and
block them
i can create different profiles for
different applications as i am as and
when i
want them and these are the alerts so
you can see that this was the first time
a network connection
was looked at from vmware and what this
allows me to do is whenever i execute a
file it can upload it to virustotal.com
and scan it as a
third-party antivirus to ensure that
there is nothing malicious on it so i
already have an antivirus over here but
if this ever gets compromised i still
can rely on a third party service
where in real time as an and when i
execute my applications uh
they would be verified and i would be
assured that
nothing is wrong with my system and this
software that i'm utilizing glasswire
basic is free and then there are paid
versions as well it's just glasswire.com
is where you're going to find this
moving on rootkit rootkits are also
malicious softwares that you allow and
unauthorized user to have access to a
computer to restrict areas of its
software
now a root kitten is a census which a
software a malicious software that
infects a machine
and prevents a from some functionality
from it like hiding data or
preventing users from running
antiviruses and
it's basically a malicious software that
is used to hide information from the
victim so that they would not realize
that they have actually been compromised
it's going to be a
difficult showing of a root kit so i
cannot show that demo to you so we're
just going to move on
and we're going to talk about ethical
hacking techniques now now when we say
ethical hacking techniques we want to
look at what kind of audits are
available when we want to do ethical
hacking so
there's a black box audit a white box
audit and a gray box audit so if i'm
invited in an organization
to conduct a test to conduct a audit
to conduct a vulnerability assessment or
a penetration test to
identify vulnerabilities and then try to
plug them out
they are going to give me three
different variations in a black box
audit they are not going to tell me
about the infrastructure they are not
going to give me any information
and they want me to start from the
basics of gathering information
identifying the systems
and based on the information that i
gather whether i am able to develop any
hacks
and compromise their infrastructure so
it will be a simulation of a hacker
who's sitting outside the organization
and trying to find a way in whereas a
white box audit is where full
infrastructure knowledge is given
anything and everything that is required
for an audit is given
and this is a simulation of an insider
attack a person sitting inside the
organization misusing
their permissions and then trying to
compromise trying to get access to data
that they do not have access to
so the simulation is from a malicious
insider a gray box is where some partial
knowledge is available
and from that partial knowledge you're
going to try to build up more
information and then you're going to try
to get
access to those resources what are the
tools that we utilize
so we have already had a couple of demos
on keyloggers
sql injection sql map and so on so forth
metasploit is a very much used tool for
penetration testing
and having knowledge on metasploit is
very much necessary as far as ethical
hacking is concerned nmap
this is a tool used for network
discovery necessary
scanner wireshark is a packet capturer
that allows you to capture packets
and analyze whatever is going on sql map
is something that we have seen a sql
injection attack tool
which generates its own queries and john
the ripper is a password tracking tool
uh backtrack used to be an operating
system that was utilized
for penetration testing however
backtrack has now been replaced by
something called kali linux and that's
the operating system that we have
utilized in all our demos where we
tried to look at sql map and those
injection attacks that we did
so what are the areas of ethical hacking
we have just talked about
all these areas as well network services
we looked at the glasswire
application that showed us how my
machine is consuming networks which
protocols are being
consumed how the connections are being
uh created
if somebody's able to install a trojan
on my machine it is going to try to
create a new
connection on the network with the
hacker to allow that hacker a backdoor
access
now if i have that glass wire or a
similar
firewall implemented it is this wire
wall that is going to detect it
and prevent that connection from
happening so if i install a software
that is certainly suspicious or that
installs something else in the
background that i may not be aware of
that tool is going to identify all the
connections that are being made and it
is going to highlight that connection
i need to go through all of those
connections and identify whether they
are legit or not
and if i find some suspicious or
doubtful i'm going to block that
connection and then i'm going to
investigate what's going on
and that's where ethical hacking comes
into the picture you want to find out if
your firewall
that you have implemented is going to
work correctly or not if the
configuration of the firewall is done
properly
or if the firewall is misconfigured is
it leaking out information
right at the same time you're looking at
web applications we looked at the ovas
broken web application where we did some
sql injection attacks
right so that was a weakness or a
vulnerability in that application
which would allow us to bypass
authentication and get access
uh to resources that we were not
authorized for and then client-side
attack should be where
uh you install keylogger at the end of
the at the client system
and then you try to capture whatever
data the user is typing in
like usernames and passwords on the
facebook and the rediff mail.com website
that we saw
and then try to misuse that information
to get access to those resources
then wi-fi networks right wi-fi is
something that we use on a regular basis
we got our smart devices nowadays
smartphones tablets phablets
that we can connect to wi-fi and start
using all our services our banking
applications and our smartphones and
thus we want to ensure that wireless
connectivity is simple and is secured
so you want to use encryption mechanisms
you want to use tools on your
smartphones antiviruses firewalls on
your smartphones to ensure that
whatever you are utilizing is going to
remain secure and then social
engineering we've looked at the phishing
website on facebook.com we've seen how
easy it is to clone
websites and host them on apache server
so if you look at it from ethical
hackers perspective the job of ethical
hacker is to simulate these kind of
attacks
that the hacker may conduct and first of
all you basically going to find out
areas where these attacks can happen
think of it from a hacker's perspective
try to simulate those attacks and see if
those attacks are going to be effective
can those attacks be prevented and can
your current security controls that have
put in place identify detect and prevent
these attacks from happening in the
first place
and that is what ethical hacking is all
about let's look at the metasploit
attack metasploit is a framework of
penetration testing that makes hacking
very simple you just
need to know how to utilize the tool you
need to identify the vulnerability
associated with the particular
exploit and then run the exploit on
metasploit
we'll be demoing this during the
practical so there are active exploits
and passive exploits
inactive exploits exploits a specific
computer runs until execution and then
exits
uses brute force and exits when an error
occurs
in a passive exploit these exploits wait
for incoming requests and exploit them
as soon as they connect they can also be
used in conjunction with
emails and web browsers so in passive
exploits we create a payload we
like a reverse connection payload we
send it to the victim
once the victim installs that software
the machine will then initiate a
connection to us
our machine will be in a lesson mode and
then we will
once the software is executed at there
and we would then try to connect and
exploit that particular vulnerability
this is the
uh practical that we'll be doing on
metasploit so let's move on with the
demos
and then we'll see what we can discuss
amongst them
all right let's have a look at some of
the demos that we had
talked about in the ethical hacking and
penetration testing module we are going
to look at three different demos the
first one is going to be a sql injection
attack that we are going to perform on
this tool that we have the second one is
a password tracking attack on windows 7
and the third one is a meter breeder
based or a metasploit based
shell shock attack on a linux based web
server so let's get cracking
i've powered on this virtual machine
which is the ovas broken web application
it is a tool that is provided for people
who want to enhance their skills and
they can practice
how to do these attacks in a legal
manner so we are going to go to this
site i'm just going to open up my
browser
the ip address is 71.132 and that's the
ovas broken web application that we want
to utilize
we're going to head off to mutilate a2
and we
are going to look at a sql injection
attack where we want to bypass
authentication now this takes us to the
login screen
so we can just try our luck here and see
that the authentication mechanism works
the account does not exist so the
username and password that we have
supplied
is not the correct one so we want to
ensure that there's a sequel database
and
we can try to attack it and see
if we can bypass the authentication now
uh what we want to do is we want to
create
a sql based malformed query that can
give us a different output so i'm just
going to type in a single quote over
here
and type login and you can see that this
is now suddenly recognized as a operator
and there's an error that is given out
compared to the login that we tried
earlier when
we used a proper text-based login
mechanism it gave us the account does
not exist
but here the single quote gave us a
error and it shows us how sql works this
is the query that we had created
now in the trainings that you have for
ethical hacking
there would be explanations of what this
queries are all about how the syntax
works here we're just going to see if we
can create a malform query
to log in as a user in this case so what
i'm going to do is
create the query over here and we're
going to give it a comparison so
we're going to give it a r one equals
one space
hyphen hyphen space and if you now click
login
you should be able to bypass
authentication and you can see user has
been authenticated
and we now have admin access to this
application
now here the sql queries need to be
crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is
there's a microsoft database and oracle
database and so on so forth and then you
have to choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
them at a demo
this is how a sql injection attack works
now let me log out here
similarly now we are in a login page the
same query worked wonders where it
allowed us to bypass
authentication so it also depends on
what kind of
a page i am and what query would be
accepted at this point in time so here
application understanding would also
come into the picture where
which function we are calling upon when
we are connected to a particular page
now this is a user lookup function right
so again here we try the same method
test
test that's not going to work
authentication error bad user or
password and if we type in the same
query over here single quote
or and give it a condition single quote
or one equals one
space hyphen knife in space now here it
is not going to log us in because this
is not a login page this is a user
lookup form so here
it would instead give us a dump of all
the databases that it has we can see all
the usernames and passwords coming in
that are stored in the user lookup field
so this is where the
understanding comes in of which query to
create at what page
we are depending upon the function that
is being called right so that's the sql
uh injection attack that we wanted to
look at let's move on to password
tracking now this is a windows 7 machine
that we have
i'm just going to do a very basic
password tracking example
we're just going to log in now here the
assumption is that we
are able to log in we have access to a
computer and we want to check out other
users who are using this computer and
see if we can find out their passwords
so that we can log in as a different
user steal data if required
and we wouldn't be to blame if there are
any locks that are created so here
we've got a tool called k enable that is
installed
right here now i'm already an
administrator on this machine and
checking out other administrators who
share the same privileges
or any other user who may be on this
system whose password i can crack
and thus i would be able to get access
through their account
and then do any malicious activity right
so
this allows me to go into a cracker tool
and it allows me to enumerate this
machine and identify
all the users and passwords that are
there in this particular machine
right so i'm just going to click on the
plus sign and i'm going to import
hashes from a local system so where are
these files stored where does windows
store its passwords in what format are
they stored
and what this tool does to retrieve
those that's something that
we all need to know as ethical hacker
right so
import the hashes from local system
click on next it's going to enumerate
that file and it is going to give you a
list of all the users
that are there so you can see the users
are hacker admin
test the one that we are logged in as
and then the user called virus as well
and you can see that this is the hash
value of the password that is being
utilized
now there's a particular format for the
hash value for
windows and how it stores but once we
have these hash values let's say if i
want to crack this password
there are various attacks that we can do
for example a dictionary based attack or
a brute force attack let's try a brute
force attack right ntlm
is the hashing mechanism that is used by
windows so we are going to try to create
an ntlm
hash attack and here we are going to use
a predetermined rule set for example we
are not sure
what characters are being utilized over
here so we just
create an attack like this using all
characters
and uh lowercase a through z uppercase a
through z
numeric zero through nine and all the
special characters let's say that
password is between 7 and 16 characters
and this is the character set that we
want to try the brute force attack on
what is a brute force attack it is an
attack where the computer is going to
try each and every permutation and
combination out of this character set
and try to figure out if the password is
going to be correct so
if we click start it's going to start
with a particular characters and then it
is going to
identify if that ntlm hash is going to
work against this character
and you can see the time is going to be
phenomenal over here
so it's not necessary that this attack
would be
viable it will be 100 successful given
the time frame
however the time frame is huge enough
for this attack to become a little bit
redundant there are other attacks that
we can
do which can easily identify this data
for us as well
but that is something that we will look
on in future videos
so that's how we can get access to users
and passwords
there are different mechanisms where
let's say we don't have login access
then what are we going to do how we can
create a fake user
login or how we can remotely access a
machine and then try to get the same
access and that is what we are going to
try to do in the next
demo on a linux machine so what we are
doing in a linux machine could
also be doable on the windows machine
with a different exploit so what i'm
going to do is
this is the linux web server that i have
that i'm going to power on
i'm going to use a kali linux machine to
hack that
device and i'm going to just power off
my windows 7 machine give it a minute
till it boots up
now this is also a demo machine that we
have which has its own
pre-configured vulnerabilities so here
we've got something from the pen testers
lab
and has a shell shock vulnerability
implemented inside
shell shock vulnerability affects linux
mac and unix-based operating systems for
a particular version of the bash
shell bash is the bone again shell which
is the command line
interface in these operating systems so
what we are trying to do here is we are
going to use the kali linux machine
try to find out the vulnerability over
here and if it exists we are going to
use metasploit to attack this machine
now the first and foremost thing is we
want to identify the ip address we have
no idea what the ip address is
we are in the same subnet so we are
assuming that we are able to connect to
this machine
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
open up a tool called
zenmap i'm going to open up a command
line interface
find out what my ip address is and my
appearance is this with a subnet mask of
two five five two five five two five
five dot zero so i want to see if there
are any other machines
that are live in the same subnet and we
are doing
a pink swipe over here to identify which
machines are live in a minute we'll get
all the ip addresses
71.1 to 133 254 and 128.
we know that we are 128 at this point in
time uh 254
is the dhcp server so we are assuming
that 133
is the machine that we want to look at
and let's then
try to see if we can scan that machine
133 and we're going to do an intense
scan
to find out which ports are open what
services are running over there and if
it is whether the pen test
machine that we were looking for you can
see of the start port 22 and port 80
and somewhere here it's going to give us
the
ports that are open and the details
about those ports
and somewhere here it will tell us that
this is the pentester lab machine that
we wanted which is
correct so now we want to do a
vulnerability analysis on this
what we are going to do is i'm going to
use another gui based tool called sparta
which i can just find out from here
sparta uses two tools in the background
nmap tool and a tool called nikto
so we're just going to start scanning
192 168 71.133 was the ip address
add to scope and over a period of time
you can see all of these
will start populating with information
there we are that's the nikto tool
coming in scanning on port 80 which is
uh which means that it's a web server
using http
it tells us it's an apache http 2.2.21
and that gives us the 22 port number as
well if we head over to the tab
of nicto or let's look at the screenshot
first this is what the website would be
looking like
and nikto gives us the options over here
it tells us that
there is a vulnerability over here for
shell shock and this is the path where
the vulnerability is going to exist
so what we are going to do we go back to
the command line sorry we open up a new
one
minimize all these other windows and we
are going to open up
metasploit metasploit is a penetration
testing tool that is used by most
hackers and ethical
hackers to test applications and test
existing exploits and vulnerabilities so
just give it a minute till it starts
you can see there are already around
1700 exploits right here
we're going to see all those exploits
with these commands
there we are sorry for the typo and it
will just give us a list of
all the exploits that are stored in
metasploit in this version
so all of these are windows based if we
scroll up we will be looking at
other vulnerabilities as well or
exploits the unique space
exploits linux osx multi-exploits
and we're looking for a exploit for um
multi-based apache or http
let's go up let's look at so this is the
one that we're looking for apache
mod cgi bash environmental executable so
what we're going to do is we're just
going to copy it
go back to the bottom say use exploit
and paste the one that we wanted press
enter
say show options so it'll ask us to
configure this
i'm just going to configure it based on
the knowledge that we have set
our host which is the remote host the
victims machine
so we put in the ip address it asks us
for the target uri so that's the path
that we saw
set target uri to
cgi hyphen bill slash status
enter now with exploit we need to find a
payload that is going to give us the
output that we want
so we say show payloads and it will give
us
a list of all the compatible payloads
with this exploit
and we want to create a reverse tcp
connection which is this so we know it's
a linux operating system we want
this payload to be set so set
payload press enter that's the payload
coming in
show options now that we have set the
payload this is the options for the
exploit and now we want to
set our options for the payloads as well
so we are creating a reverse tcp
connection
which means we are remotely executing
code at the victim side
and making the victim connect back to
our machine which means we need to set
up a listener so i need to put my ip
address over here
set localhost or lhost 192 168
71.128 which was our ip address
show options again just to ensure
everything is fine
which looks like it is and we then type
in the word exploit so that it will
start this attack
you can see that it has created a
mutable session at the victim site
and it has opened up a session so if i
do a pwd now pwd is a linux command for
present working directory and it will
show us that we'll
connect it to where w cgi hyphen bin
do an ls it will list all the files
that's the status file over there
do a cd backslash it will take us to the
root of this
machine now remember we saw the
passwords on a windows machine
similarly we can head over to the cd etc
folder
ls and you can see these files psswd
and shadow now psswd is the file where
linux stores its usernames and shadow is
the file where
passwords are shown so do a cat command
psswd
and you can see these users coming up so
you can see the last user pen test lab
and you can see there are no passwords
so let's do a cat
shadow and that's your hash value for
the password that we have
for the user pen test lab so these are
the different attacks that we need to
understand
and we need to create based on the
vulnerabilities that exist
on different machines so we just looked
at windows and linux and how we can
exploit them
depending on existing vulnerabilities as
an ethical hacker
this is uh what we need to learn in our
trainings
and then we need to clear our exams
based on this knowledge of how these
things work
so that we get certified and then we can
position ourselves
for the penetration testing jobs now
let's begin with who is a certified
ethical hacker
a certified ethical hacker is a person
who is also known as an ethical hacker
an ethical hacker
is just the opposite of a hacker a
hacker is a person who with malicious
intent
tries to misuse vulnerabilities that
they have identified in an organization
structure
and then gain access to unauthorized
data whereas an ethical hacker
does the same thing they try to locate
the weakness they try to look at the
vulnerabilities
and they see how they can be misused
however
the intent is completely different and
that is what differentiates a hacker
from an ethical hacker
hacker would be a criminal with a
malicious intent
who would try to misuse and personally
gain
by doing criminal activity from that
particular activity that they have done
whereas ethical hacker
would try to help the organization in an
authorized manner
so that's where the permission comes
into the picture the ethical hacker has
permission
from the organization to conduct some
activity that would identify
vulnerabilities or weaknesses in the
information technology structure of that
organization
and then once they have been identified
the ethical hacker would then help the
organization
to plug those vulnerabilities rather
than misuse those vulnerabilities
so any person who completes ch version
10 certification
is known as a certified ethical hacker
so there's a certification once you
complete that once you pass the exams
you can essentially call yourself as a
certified ethical hacker and you're
going to get a certificate with the same
terminology so as you can see in the
diagram your responsibility would be as
a certified ethical hacker would be
with the proper permission of the
organization with the authorization
coming in with contracts coming in
you would legally help the organization
to identify those weaknesses and
vulnerabilities
and once you find them you're going to
report them to the organization and
you're going to help the organization
with remediation plan which will help
them remediate
mitigate and resolve the vulnerabilities
that you've identified
thus making the organization's security
structure a lot better
based on which black hat hackers or
malicious hackers
would be unable to attack the
organization so what is
ch version 10 now this course was
initially introduced in september 2015
and i think if you look at the
versioning this is the 10th version
that is there in the market so
essentially ch or the certified ethical
hacking course as the course itself has
been
for a long time in the industry it's a
very well accepted course
and it's a well-renowned course the
current version as it is
was uh introduced in september 2015 and
is one of the toughest
certifications in the cyber security
field this includes a lot of information
that you have to
learn that you have to know before you
can attempt the certification you will
master
all ethical lacking methodologies that
are used in penetration testing and
ethical hacking situations what does
that mean
that means that ceh version 10 is a
structured course that will help you
look at all the phases that are used in
ethical hacking all the terminologies
that are utilized all the tools that are
utilized in such a manner
that you can penetration test or a
vulnerability assessment
and identify and test the
vulnerabilities for their complexity
and this course once you complete the
course you would have mastered all the
ethical hacking
techniques that are required there are
two exams one is a written exam and the
other is a practical exam now you can
opt for either or
the written exam is basically a multiple
choice question exam
where they'll ask you scenario based
questions and you have to answer those
questions
that is something that we're going to
look into during this video
the practical exam is basically a
simulation exam where they give you a
scenario and you have to complete
some complete those tests and prove that
you are a good ethical hacker
based on the report that you give if the
report tallies to what the test was
you would be clearing that exam so
practical exam is a little bit tougher
it's more hands-on
it tests this actual skills that you
would perform in a hacking scenario or
ethical hacking scenario does the
practical exam
going to be that much tougher the
written exam to give it credence
tests you a lot on your mentality on
your thought process
on your judgment characteristics so they
will give you a scenario
and ask you what do you think is
happening what does this attack
trend amount to or would be then what
what would be the next step in the
particular attack that they're
describing
does it's more of an intellectual test
where your
when your thought process are being
checked and uh you are giving this exam
so what would be the difference between
these exams in a practical exam
you would be conducting all those steps
yourself and you would be
reaching a conclusion so here
essentially you're being tested
on the skills that you have developed on
the execution part of it
and to see whether you can execute a
test end to end whereas
in a written exam you would be put in
the middle of a test
where you have to assume something where
you have to understand what the steps
would have been
performed in the in the previous steps
and what would be the expected result
and you're supposed to analyze that and
then come to the
correct answer so if there is a question
which which exam is better written or
practical
the answer to that is from intellectual
perspective a written exam would be a
lot tougher than a practical exam
and from an execution perspective a
practical exam would be tougher than a
written exam
so it depends on us which exam we want
to give both of them are widely accepted
and well respected
in the information security field so
it's just the option
that we choose which exam we want to
give now this
course the version 10 course is purely a
tag-based course
okay it is an offensive course there's
no defensive mechanisms
so if you're looking for questions of
how to secure yourself on the internet
how to securely configure operating
system or how to securely configure a
server
how to configure a firewall this is not
the certification
this basically talks about attacking
those devices so if you come across a
firewall how would you test a firewall
how would you identify vulnerabilities
in those and how would you bypass a
firewall
similarly if you come across a server
how are you going to attack and hack the
server
let it be windows um linux based so this
basically becomes a attack based course
you're looking at offensive mechanisms
over here and not defensive ones at all
so what's new in this version in this
version there's a new module
for iot internet of things it focuses on
emerging attacks vectors like cloud
artificial intelligence and
machine learning it basically talks
about smart devices and it talks about
the vulnerabilities the risk that the
smart devices face in today's world
uh for example it will tell you about
the industries that are utilizing all
these smart devices
why are they utilizing it for what kind
of devices they are utilizing
and what are the risks within those
devices it will also give you a lot of
tools
for you to practice upon to identify
such iot devices
what would constitute an iot or internet
of things device any device which has an
ip address and can connect to the
internet and create data so even your
smart watch
your smartphone your cars that have
internet connectivity nowadays
uh your google homes amazon alexas
all of these devices would come under
the iot umbrella
and have you ever wondered about sitting
at home having a wi-fi
having all of these devices even a smart
tv if you will connected to the wi-fi
and have you ever questioned how a
hacker would then be able to access your
home through all of these devices
record information and basically just
spy on you
similarly an organization where they're
utilizing iot
they would be vulnerable for the same
vulnerabilities and
this course does include iot security to
a certain extent
where we talked about vulnerabilities
and how to identify those
vulnerabilities
in iot then there's a new vulnerability
analysis module where it gives you risk
assessment it talks about cvss scoring
systems
it talks about how to do a vulnerability
management program in the first place
what are the steps required in a world
liberty management program how should it
be reputable and how it should be
measurable as a program
and what should be the outcome so
basically it will give you a structured
way of how to
do a vulnerability management assessment
and
how do you want to achieve the end goal
thus leading you to a penetration test
so all the modules are leveled up what
do you mean by leveled up that means
they've been updated to the latest
tools latest standards latest
technologies so you've got cryptographic
attacks you have
got attacks on applications like sql
injection we will be talking about
packet sniffing using
various tools all of these are upgraded
which means they are up to the latest
operating system so even
when we do this course you'll be looking
at operating systems like windows 10
windows 8
windows server 2012 windows server 2016
kali linux machines
android machines and ubuntu desktop as
well
so all of the operating systems are
latest the tools are latest
and you will be interacting with these
tools and then there is a mobile
security toolkit as well
which will help you do a penetration
test on a mobile
device so these are what is new in
version
10. now let's talk about the roles and
responsibilities that ethical hacker
should have when they actually go into
the world
now what are the responsibilities rules
what are the capabilities that we should
have
that we should be able to look at
scripts that would test for
vulnerability so for example a sql
injection attack
it's a script-based attack let's say a
cross-site scripting attack that is
again going to be a script-based attack
so we uh maybe we want to go ahead a
little bit
look at windows systems and do a
powershell attack and know
about partial scripting a little bit if
you look at linux windows there's a bash
shell where there's bash scripting and
you'll want to learn that scripting as
well
now the course doesn't include all these
scripting languages
it does help you understand what these
scripting languages are and it does have
some basic introduction to how these
languages can be utilized to create
those scripts
then we also want to develop tools to
increase security you want to look at
those commands that are utilized on all
operating systems you want to look at
the capabilities of the operating
systems
of how to create security parameters and
ensure the operating systems and
applications devices are secure
uh you should be able to perform risk
assessment now when you say risk
assessment
risk assessment is the likelihood of an
attack being actually executed on an
organization
based on the threats and the
vulnerabilities that we have identified
so risk assessment is something that
you find out a vulnerability and then
you try to figure out in a hypothetical
manner
of what is the likelihood of that
vulnerability being exploited by a
hacker
if they find that vulnerability and if
they do execute that
what is the impact that is going to
happen on the organization
and what is the penalties or the
replications
that the organization is going to face
if that vulnerability is exploited
that's what a risk assessment is then we
should also be able to
develop security policies or set up
security policies and implement them
to ensure that the security mechanisms
are standardized
and are consistent and then we should
also
look at training staff for network
security to ensure that they are aware
of these vulnerabilities and they know
what their responsibilities are
to maintain some semblance of security
in the organization
so why do we want to become a certified
ethical hacker now
since you're watching this video it's
easy to assume that we all are
interested in security we all are
interested in hacking but hacking is not
a real job
for us to get a job in the industry on a
security parameter or information
security parameter we want to become a
certified ethical hacker
so if you look at the popular hacking
cases that have happened in 1990s there
was a national crackdown on criminals
microsoft nt operating system was hacked
now this was back in the 90s when
security wasn't that much evolved and
there were a lot of attacks back then
uh that crippled infrastructure that
crippled banks when they started
realizing that computing isn't as easy
as it seems
of course if you use a computer the
functionality is always there but if the
functionality is not properly configured
you're just exposing yourself to cyber
criminals where they're going to steal
information
and your organization may just go
bankrupt because of that
in 2013 an example adobe reported
2.9 million accounts as stolen in 2016
kaspersky which is a internet security
firm uh announced that there was 758
million malicious attacks that occurred
worldwide
imagine that 758 million malicious
attacks
that were identified and reported in
2018 facebook reported a loss of 30
millions to
accounts that were stolen 2018 again
quora
reported 100 million customer accounts
being stolen and
in 2018 again marriott 500 million
travelers accounts stolen and
manipulated now when you say account for
a stolen how does it affect the
organizations now first and foremost
if those accounts were stolen that means
usernames and passwords were cracked and
those accounts may have contained credit
card information
or may have contained some personal
information that would identify the
personal
the person and does make them gullible
for a social engineering attack or an
identity theft attack
so it has a cascading effect if i would
have been affected
or you would have been affected with
these attacks the repercussions would
have been catastrophic your credit card
information being stolen that means
somebody else would have misused it
and you would have uh seen a huge bill
come to you come your way
now you can go back to the bank and
dispute that but that that's again
a dispute that you're trying to uh have
with the bank for something that you
didn't do which requires a lot of energy
and
a lot of time and at the end of it
somebody has to pay for that particular
loss now in this scenario the bank would
have had to bear the loss but then
that's a loss for the bank and bank
doesn't want to do that
and that's where they would try to hire
certified ethical hackers
who try to test these vulnerabilities
and plug them in
so that the end consumer is also secured
the bank is also secure
right in this case uh marriott there
were 500 million travelers accounts that
were stolen a lot of credit card
information
uh was uh leaked out email email
accounts were
hacked and compromised and thus there
was a lot of
replication that happened now the thing
is that there are also
laws that these organizations need to
adhere to that
tell the organizations how to keep their
information secure
and also have penalties in place if the
organization
gets hacked and the penalties are pretty
severe so organizations do not want to
get hacked or do not want to get
compromised
not only from the customers perspective
where they would be losing customers
losing reputations and then thus facing
losses
but also from a legislative perspective
where they would have to pay fines to
the government
for the frauds that have happened so
these are some of the popular hacking
cases that have cost these organizations
quite a lot of money
and does uh they have a lot of security
in mind
uh if you look at the news uh in bbc
news there was something reported from a
french police that there was a virus
that infected more under 850 000
computers worldwide now on the similar
lines if you
remember ransomwares and if you look at
wannacry that happened in 2018 or 2017
it also cost the world four billion
dollars in losses
during that just one small month of its
infection
then apple google basically disclosed
that a large-scale hacking effort
was targeted at apple devices and this
has been uh it has reported that there
was a sustained effort to hack
high iphones over a period of at least
two years
which means that there's a specific
target towards apple consumers and they
are at a higher risk of getting hacked
than others then the texas government
organizations hit by ransomware attack
so hackers have infected 23
organizations connected to local
government
in the u.s state of texas with
ransomware that means that their
databases
have been encrypted the government
themselves do not have access to that
database the databases could have been
compromised by the hackers
and that means that whatever services
were being provided to the users based
on that database
may no longer be available to the end
users because of the ransomware
now moving on with these why won't do we
want to become a certified ethical
hacker
increased attacks lead to more job
openings now if you look at ransomware
the wannacry attack that happened in
2017 there was a knee-jerk reaction
given by the
rest of the world for i.t security
suddenly budgets or started opening up
suddenly people wanted more ethical
hackers on their payrolls to test for
vulnerabilities
in uk and europe we have gdpr uh which
is again another law
that imposes cv of penalties on
organizations that get
hacked and for not having proper
security and a vulnerability assessment
and penetration
testing program in place so that leads
to a lot of job requirements as well
where
organizations look at people with this
special skill set
to help them mitigate the
vulnerabilities to keep to safeguard
them
and their customers from hackers and
also from penalties
from law enforcement and governments so
does the demand keeps on increasing for
ethical hackers which automatically
means that the salaries are going to
increase as well
so more the demand lesser the supply
higher the salaries
that's plain economics then challenge
hacker with malicious intent
so from ethical hackers perspective it
is our duty to safeguard an organization
which means that will be pitched against
hackers and we have to ensure that those
hackers would be challenged to the
maximum limit before they even try to
get access
to any of the resources that we are
trying to protect it offers
a boost in your career so more uh
efforts that you put in more
vulnerabilities that you find the better
the career prospects that you have
and the better job aspects that you're
going to get and this also
lets you keep yourself updated on the
latest technology as the technology
progresses
as we evolve on technology security will
also evolve
and the ethical hacker would need to
keep themselves updated on these
technologies
so this is what is a plus point to
become a certified
ethical hacker
so why do we want to get the
certification and what would it mean by
being a ceh certified
individual take this into consideration
you are applying for jobs
and you have been applying for cyber
security related jobs of course
and you go in for an interview in the
interview you are asked quite a few
questions
and they will be testing you on cyber
security concepts
so they will be asking you a lot of
technical questions about cyber
security about information security and
any other related topic so let's say in
a few minutes into the interview
there are some concepts that you have
not brushed your skills upon and they
ask you about certifications
and one of the main certifications that
is sought after is the ceh certification
and if you're not certified that's where
things can become a little bit
problematic where
organizations today very proactively
start looking for people
or candidates who are already certified
rather than take them on board and get
them certified
so in this scenario uh having a
certification would obviously help not
only to be
shortlisted for the job but the
certification
involves a lot of training which would
help you understand the concepts
and prepare you for the interview a lot
better as well
right so getting yourself certified is
quite necessary in today's world
let's look at what the certification is
all about the certification
involves a very hands-on training
that trains an individual into thinking
about cyber security from hackers
perspective
and developing this mindset is very
important because
to catch a thief we have to think like a
thief teaches the candidate to spot
vulnerabilities in a system so it trains
you
on how to identify flaws how to verify
that they exist
and then how to treat them as well like
i said this is a very sought after
certification and companies
look for people who already certified as
ceh or a certified ethical hacker
so what is this certification all about
this is a globally accepted
certification
and it tests the knowledge that a
candidate will have
about threats and their prevented
preventive mechanisms
so the certification the exam itself
will test you on the parameters the
training
would provide you with all the
information that you require to clear
the exam
and to gain knowledge from a real world
perspective
so to train a candidate to think like a
hacker it will train the candidate to
use the tools to identify those flaws
uh to spot those flaws in the first
place
and it will give an understanding to the
candidate
where to look for those flaws in the
first place so essentially when you get
certified as a certified ethical hacker
you become a white hat hacker or an
ethical hacker
which means that you will be looking at
flaws
ethically and reporting them to those
organizations
the certifying authority is the ec
council it is a very well known and a
widely accepted certification authority
across the globe
it is based out of the united states but
the certification is valid
across the globe so what does it take to
take the exam and who can take the exam
in the first place
now the basic criteria is that
candidates should be 18 years and about
so any person who has completed an
official ec council training is eligible
to attend the exam without going through
an application process
so there are two ways you can actually
attend the exam you either have work
experience that means you're already in
the cyber security space you already
have some
you already have some hands-on knowledge
and you want to give the exam
in that scenario you just have to prove
that you've got two years of experience
with network or information security and
then you can apply to ec council to
directly appear for the exam
without attending the training else you
can
then approach ec council and register
yourself for a training course after
which you can give the exam so there are
two ways
that you can deal with it what are the
fees for this exam
now the fee itself is 500 for the exam
candidates who take the second route
where they prove that they have
experience and they directly want to
appear for the exam
there is another additional 100 of
application fee that they have to pay to
ec council
for them to verify that you actually
have that experience and then allow you
to
appear for the exam so what are the exam
questions like what
what is the exam all about the exam code
is three one two hyphen five
zero and there are 125 questions that
need to be answered in four hours
now that sounds like a lot of time but
trust me it isn't
the questions are descriptive in nature
they give you a scenario you have to
identify those keywords based on the
knowledge and the understanding that you
have
and then gauge the correct answer for
that particular scenario
and the scenarios could be a little bit
complex could be a little bit confusing
the exam will be a multiple choice
question exam so one questions with four
answers
if any question has multiple answers
they will mention it in the
question itself the past percentage cuts
off
at around 60 to 85 percent so there is
no fixed percentile
every question has a different grade
every question has a different value
and based on the questions that you have
been asked and the correctness of the
answers
you would either pass somewhere between
60 to 85 percent
the results are immediate so once you
complete the exam and you submit it
it will let you know that itself whether
you have cleared or not
so what are the skills that you require
for this exam you must have very good
networking skills and when we say
networking skills you should know your
protocols you should know how
computers communicate with each other
the protocols like https ftp smtp
and anything about the osi layer you
should be good with your operating
systems
the candidate should also have a very
good knowledge about operating systems
and when we say operating systems we
want the candidate to know about
troubleshooting methods
and how the operating system work in the
first manner
so you should have some basic skills
about operating systems and the
configuration of these operating systems
you should also know the different types
of cyber attacks such as social
engineering phishing and how to prevent
these attacks
so this is the exam skills the training
prepares you with all these skills
the candidate must be able to hack into
an organization system
with permission and erase all digital
evidences so
the training itself will get you
accustomed with all the hacking phases
how a hack is constructed how a hack is
made more effective
and how the hack evolves and later on
how you can
delete all the evidences of the hack
that has happened so for the exam
you should have or you should be very
good with your networking skills
understanding protocols and how they
work
configuring operating systems and
troubleshooting them
you should be able to classify different
cyber attacks and know how to
launch them as well and you should be
able to hack into devices
and erase all digital evidences that may
have happened
password cracking and cryptography is
also a very much required skill to clear
the exam
there must be a few rules followed and
there is a code of ethics from ec
council so they essentially give you a
non-disclosure agreement
before you start the training which you
have to go through
and you have to sign it submit it to ec
counsel only then are you allowed to go
forward with the exam
so what are the exam all about what are
the topics within that exam
and what kind of questions would you get
so there are seven
domains in this training based on which
they will ask you questions when you say
background background is nothing but
your knowledge on networking skills
uh your knowledge on a little bit of
operating systems
how communications happen how protocols
work
and so on so forth analysis would be
where you analyze certain attacks and
you're able to
analyze let's say packets and based on
those packets you can
identify whether it's a legitimate
packet or is it a malicious packet with
any malicious data within it then with
security tools you
are able to talk about security as in
the
concepts of security like
confidentiality integrity and
availability triad
the ia identification authentication
authorization
and accountability trial uh aspects and
various other concepts that are there in
security so you'll be questioned
on those topics as well tools and
programs ethical hacking carries a lot
of tools
and you should be conversant with those
tools uh
in the during the training there will be
a hundreds of tools that
you would be going through and you would
be facing questions on these tools
so there would be some basic questions
like commands that would be given to you
to identify what that command would
execute
or there would be a specific scenario
given to you and then they would ask you
which is the
most uh suitable tool that you would
utilize to crack that particular
scenario
and then there's the methodology of
course of how or which steps
would you take in this particular attack
to be successful then we talk about
policies
and the ethics so as you can see all of
these domains have different
weightage in the exam 21.79 for your
background
so you can see the background
information is very much important
operating systems networking
a little bit of applications a little
bit of architecture of how things are
deployed
now ceh is normally an advanced
certification right
so there are a few presumptions that you
already know a little bit about
active directory how operating systems
work how identity management works
so there's a little bit of presumption
that you have these background knowledge
but in the training you can be prepped
up for that knowledge as well so it does
contain a little bit of insights about
how these things
work analysis is where you're looking at
some scenarios
and based on the evidence is given to
you you can analyze what's going on so
that's a 20.73 percent
security which is the main topic is at
23.73
tools and programs related to security
would be at 28.91
the methodologies would carry a
weightage of 8.77
policies 1.90 and ethics 2.17
so you have 125 questions you can figure
out
percentile wise how many questions you
would get on each of these domains
so let's have a look at these domains a
little bit more the background is about
network and communication technologies
again like i said protocols procedures
services how computers work so ports
on a computer how uh how ports are
utilized by services
and how communications happen over these
services and these ports
how we can scan these ports to identify
what's going on and then try to find out
vulnerabilities within them
then we have got information security
technologies and the information
security threats as well so
when i want to launch an attack on a
device where would i
find vulnerabilities is it just on the
network do i look at the operating
system do i look at
different applications that are there on
the operating system and so on so forth
so where are the threats that's
something that we need to identify and
that's what
this domain deals with so 27 questions
from this domain then analysis and
assessment information security
assessment and analysis
and the security assessment process so
let's say you're in a penetration test
and you want to launch an attack what is
the assessment that you want to do
before you launch that attack what is
the process you want to conduct
and how you're going to analyze the
vulnerability in the first place to
identify
which penetration test or which attack
you should
do at that particular point in time then
security would talk about information
security controls
controls would be all the security
elements that you can implement
to prevent uh hacking so firewalls ids
ips
antiviruses or endpoints all of these
would be included in this domain
information security attack detection so
it's not only about how you can attack
you also want to know if you're being
attacked in the first place
so analysis would basically identify how
you're being attacked
and the detection is where where you
first detect that something is wrong
after which you can analyze it
right and how we can prevent uh security
attacks happening at your organization
as well so which firewall would fit
at what osi layer what uh in the
architectural aspect
where do you want to place a id ids or
an ips
where would you want to place a firewall
wherever you want to place a utm
to have a layered approach a structured
structured approach
towards security where a hacker would
have to peel off layers of security
to reach the data that they wanted to
get access to in the first place
so there will be 30 questions from the
security domain 16 questions on the
analysis and assessment domain
the fourth domain is the tool systems
and programs so this
is where all the tools that you would
have utilized
resume so this is where all the tools
that you have utilized
in the ethical lacking scenario and
there will be questions asked about
those tools
so in the training there are some tools
that are prescribed
in the courseware you'll have to
concentrate on those tools you'll have
to get your hands on on those tools to
understand how those tools work
and then give appropriate answers in
this domain so there would be 36
questions
for tool systems and programs then the
fifth domain is procedures and
methodology
information security procedures and
assessment methodologies
would be asked over here so how would
you uh conduct a test how would you
conduct a vulnerability assessment
what is the method and the procedures
that you would follow in conducting
these
tests so there would be around 11
questions for this domain
the sixth one is regulations and
policies so this is all about
uh some basics that you need to be aware
about
for information security policies and
frameworks
like iso 27001 pci dss and these
regulations that are available in the
real world that you can that
can help you or guide you to place a
security architecture
on your organization these questions are
not going to be in depth
about any of the laws or policies it's
just
checking your awareness whether you're
aware of these laws
or policies and where they can be
implemented so we can see that only
a couple of questions that would come in
regulations and policies
and then ethics ethics is the code of
conduct
of how you are expected to behave as an
ethical hacker what is expected out of
your job role
what you should be doing and what you
shouldn't be doing so there would be
around three questions
of ethics in the exam now let's look at
a few sample questions from the exam as
well so this will help you
get an idea what the exam questions
would be so consider the attack scenario
given below there are five steps listed
step one starts with
user browsers a web page the second step
is where user
web server replies with the requested
page and sets the cookie on the user's
browser
in the third step attacker steals the
cookie by either
creating an attack of uh on the network
for sniffing or at the application with
cross-site scripting
or sending a fake mail or a hosting a
fake website
by a social engineering attack which is
a phishing attack
in the fourth step attacker gets access
using whatever they have done and orders
a product using modified cookies and in
the fifth step the product is actually
delivered to the attacker's address
whereas the bill is footed by the
victim so what is the attack that is
happening here identify the web
application attack is it a session
fixation attack
is it a unvalidated redirect attack is
it a cookie poisoning attack or is it a
denial of service attack so again going
through these steps
which of these would be the correct
answer in this scenario
it is c which is a cookie poisoning
attack because if you look at the steps
the attacker basically hijacked the
cookie or stole the cookie
and then modified it to be utilized for
some malicious reasons
second question which one of the
following scanning techniques do
attackers use
to bypass firewall rules logging
mechanisms and also hide themselves as
usual network traffic
a stealth scanning technique b tcp
connect scanning technique
c maintaining access or d fin scanning
technique
now here as you can understand we need
to know what these techniques
are right so what does a fin scan mean
what is maintaining access what is tcp
connect
what does tcp mean this tcp is
transmission control protocol
how does it work so when you connect
using tcp what is actually happening in
the back end
that is what the knowledge is all about
and in here
the correct answer is a stealth scanning
technique so what do we mean by stealth
how can we achieve that which tools help
us achieve that
that is what we want to gain an
understanding in
before we can attempt the exam question
three which of the following wi-fi
chalking method refers to drawing
symbols
in public places to advertise open wi-fi
networks
war walking wall flying war chalking or
war driving
now here we need to know first that
there is something known as
wi-fi chalking right and there are some
symbols that are utilized globally and
they are recognized globally that
standardized by the way
and these symbols represent some type of
wi-fi networks for example open wi-fi
which means
you can freely connect to the wi-fi or
paid wi-fi where you have to pay before
you can connect to the wi-fi
or once you get connected you're first
to have to make a payment
only then the internet would be
activated right so
for different wi-fi mechanisms there are
different options that can be utilized
and which of the question is which of
the wi-fi talking method refers to
drawing these symbols in public places
to advertise open wi-fi
so in this the answer is what shocking
now the question here itself is a little
bit
so here the question itself is is a
little bit uh misleading because it
mentions wi-fi chalking in the question
itself
and that would then lead us to whether
what shocking is a correct answer or not
so
some of the questions could be a little
bit misleading so let's start looking at
the certifications
so to be an ethical hacker you must hold
a certification which specializes in
ethical hacking or in cyber security
companies look for candidates who are
globally certified
when we say globally certified they're
looking for a certificate that has been
given by an organization that is
recognized globally and
is well accepted in the industry so
these are the top
five certifications our candidate can
obtain the first one
become a certified ethical hacker then
there is global information assurance
certification penetration tester
then offensive security certified
professional comptria pentest plus
and finally the license penetration
tester now these certifications
are offered by different organizations
all of these organizations are
recognized
globally and their certifications are
well accepted
in the technical space so let's start
off with the certified ethical hacker
and we'll look at
the organizations that provide these
certifications and how we can attain
them
so ceh or certified ethical hacker in
its
current form is in its version 10 it's
been revised
and updated over a period of time ec
council is the certifying authority for
ceh they have their own authorized
training centers
through which you can attend trainings
give those exams get yourself certified
and thus become globally certified and
can be eligible to apply for security
related jobs it is a very well known
certification and is widely accepted at
the same time
it would test the candidate's knowledge
of security threats and preventive
measures now there are two types of
exams that you can give with ceh
one is a multiple choice question exam
which is theoretical in nature
they ask you questions and you answer
the correct uh you select the correct
answers
if you clear you get certified the
second certification
nowadays is where there's a practical
exam associated with it
that's a you'll have to purchase the
voucher for that exam
and give that exam the practical exam is
held in a virtual lab where they
you're given scenarios and based on
those scenarios you have to
resolve the questions given to you and
give
proof of the resolution which would then
get you certified as an ethical hacker
the theoretical exam
in this scenario is the fees is around
500
this is for the multiple choice question
exam where you can pay the fees and you
can
attend through a online portal and you
can give the exam directly
the exam is four hours long in which you
have to answer 125 questions
now four hours for 125 questions seems a
long
time but it isn't it's a very technical
exam there are scenario-based questions
and it would take some time for you to
analyze and understand the question
and then identify the equivalent correct
answer so it's a very
competitive exam and you'll have to
study really hard
to clear this exam as well the cutoff
for passing
varies from 60 to 85 percent so there is
no
exact grade and all the questions have
different weightages
so depending on the questions that have
been given to you and the way that you
have answered them
you would pass at either 60 or you would
pass when you scored 85 percent
once you are ceh certified which is a
very technical certification
you will be qualified to apply for job
roles as a penetration tester or a
security engineer
these are job roles where you would be
responsible of
ethically trying to attack applications
servers switches and try to find out
vulnerabilities within them
the training of this certification will
make you adept in most of these tools
that are required there are a lot of
practicals in this
training and if you successfully
completed those practicals clearing the
exam is a
easy task with the practicals comes your
knowledge
and would help you understand how you
would be performing penetration tests in
the real world
an average annual salary in the usa for
a cea certified person is around 91 000
and in india is around four like 76 000
odd rupees
the salaries would vary as far as
organizations are concerned
uh more established organizations can
afford to pay a little bit more
but these are average salaries that we
have seen
across the market the next certification
is the g pen
also known as the global information
assurance certification penetration
tester
this certification looks into the
different pen testing practices and
methods also focuses on the various
problems and pen testing
so again this is where you're getting
certified as a penetration tester
so it's again a technical certification
where your knowledge on networking
applications and security of which will
be tested
you will be trained on this of course so
the training will include
all these areas where you need to focus
identify those problems
and thus be ready for the real world
scenarios
the candidate will have to understand
networking concepts and operating
systems such as linux and windows
and you should be very well aware of the
tcp protocols
this is true for any of the technical
certifications for ethical hacking
giac is the certification provider it's
again a very well renowned
and well accepted certification
authority across the globe
the exam fees are one thousand eight
hundred and ninety nine dollars
eighty two two hundred and fifteen
questions to be answered in three hours
now why 82 215 it depends on the test
that has been associated
and depending on how you're answering
those questions
uh you would be given those many number
of questions
to begin with but all of these need to
be answered in three hours
74 is the past percentage that is
required to clear this exam
the average annual salary in the usa is
around 96
000 while in india it is around
similar to certified ethical hacking
then looking at the next certification
from offensive security
called the oscp offensive security
certified professional
this is another penetration testing
certification
highly technical in nature and it is an
entirely hands-on certification the
previous
two certifications that we saw we talked
about ceh where there are two different
exams you could either take the
theoretical exam
and give your mcqs or you could take the
practical one here you don't have an
option
this is a practical exam so the test is
conducted on a virtual network
so they send out instructions to you
there's a virtual lab that is given out
to you
and they give you the questions and you
have to perform those assessments
create those reports and provide it to
the certifying authority
in this case offensive security if you
match their criterias of whatever you
have identified in those reports
you get certified here the requirements
of good understanding of networking
protocols
how systems function how kali linux
operating system functions
and the candidate must complete
offensive securities penetration testing
with the kali linux course
and pass the hands-on exam so this
focuses purely on kali linux kali line
next is an operating system that is
freely distributed over the internet and
comes
structured with around 300 plus tools
used for ethical hacking
so this course totally relies on kali
linux
for you to use as a tool set for
penetration testing the certificate
provider as stated is
offensive security the name of the
course is oscp
offensive security certified
professional exam is around 800
to 1550. now understand that this exam
is technical and is hands-on so
for you to prepare for this exam they
come up with virtual labs where you can
start practicing
and honing your skills depending on the
number of days
for which you have purchased the access
to that particular labs the amount will
vary from eight hundred dollars which
would be the minimum
access days available to one thousand
five hundred and fifty dollars where
the maximum number of days would be
given to you for practicing
once you're ready even during the time
spa time span of where you have that
access
once you're ready for the exam you can
they can attempt the exam and clear
the average annual salary is similar
around 91 000
for the u.s market and 905 000 rupees
in the indian market then looking at the
compchia pen test plus
compxia is another certification
authority or a certification provider
a training provider that that will help
you get yourself certified in the
ethical hacking space
so they have certification called pen
test plus which is
focused towards penetration testing so
it is an intermediate level
certification it assesses the
vulnerability assessment and the
penetration testing skills
of a candidate here the training will
provide you with all the essentials
where it will help you identify how to
do vulnerability assessments how to
identify those vulnerabilities
and then which tools to utilize for what
kind of a penetration test
for the requirements a minimum of three
to four years of hands-on experience in
the information security field
also a computer security plus or a
network plus
or equivalent knowledge is required so
in the network plus
they talk about securing networks and
they help you understand the osi layers
the tcp layers
and help you understand the protocols
and all of those things
so having that knowledge is an added
advantage the certificate provider is
comchia
and the cost of the exam is around 349
dollars
maximum number of questions is 85
and i think it's a three hour exam
the passing percentage is uh scoring 750
marks out of a possible
900. so the scale is the minimum you can
ever score is 100
if you're completely unbe prepared the
maximum you can score is nine hundred
uh you get a leeway of 150 marks for
your
certifications so you have to score a
minimum of 750 to clear the exam
average annual salary for your kamcha
certified penetration test
plus professional is 97 000
in the u.s market and in the indian
market it would be around 5 lakh rupees
then comes the license penetration
tester now this is an advanced
certificate again from ec council
this is where ec council gives you a
license
which certifies that you have undergone
thorough training
and have cleared your exam in which you
can
conduct or lead a audit for
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing
it is an expert level certification
comes after the ceh certification
it is the ultimate test which tests this
candidate's penetration testing skills
so there are two certifications over
here
one is the ecsa ec council certified
security analyst
once you clear that you get you can
appear for the license penetration
tester
both of these are hands-on
certifications so you will be given a
virtual lab you will be given a scenario
in which you'll have to perform some
assessments create reports
submit it to the ec council they will
analyze your reports if they meet the
criterias that have been identified
you would then be certified as a
licensed penetration tester the
candidate must be above 18 years of age
a re-certification is required every
three years so the validity is
three years after three years you will
have to be recertified or there is a
continuing point education
system over there where you can score
points by publishing articles by
attending trainings or giving out
trainings and carrying areas of
recertified
it is preferred that the candidate has
ceh and the ecsa certification
so the previous certification that we
saw certified ethical hacker
and then the ecsa ec council certified
security analyst
after which you can appear for the lpt
license penetration tester
the certificate provider again is ec
council the license penetration tester
exam has a different process the
candidate must purchase an exam
dashboard for 899 dollars which is valid
for a year
so once you purchase the voucher the
validity is one year
you can prepare within that one year and
then give the exam and
attain the certification only once
you're ready the exam can be
scheduled and you can give that exam the
exam consists of three different levels
each level has three different
challenges the candidate must pass
at least one challenge in order to
qualify for the next level
and for each level the exam is six hours
so this is a grueling exam this is
hands-on they're giving you
challenges and they are going to test
you on your skills
as a penetration tester so be ready to
be very hands-on
for this kind of a certification average
annual salary in the us is around 100
000
and above and in india 825 000 and above
next shruti will guide you through the
career of an ethical hacker
with the increase in the number of cyber
crimes across the globe
there is also an increase in the number
of cyber security jobs and the role of
an ethical hacker tops the list
hi guys this is shruti from simply learn
and today i will run you through
this video on ethical hacking career so
let's get started and explore the world
of ethical hacking
let's begin with a few facts did you
know that by the year 2021 there will be
3.5 million cyber security job openings
that is a huge number isn't it and also
according to the u.s bureau of
labor statistics there will be 28
increase in the number of jobs from 2016
to 2026
for information security analysts which
includes ethical hackers
this proves that there is a great demand
for ethical hackers
at the moment as i mentioned earlier the
number of cyber crimes across the world
will increase
as the digital era will only continue to
grow
organizations will be on the lookout to
hire professionals who can
fight these cyber crimes and protect the
company's data
and to fight these cyber crimes we will
require individuals who can think like a
hacker
and who is that well to do this job we
have ethical hackers
as you might be knowing an ethical
hacker is trained to discover system
vulnerabilities an ethical hacker is
also known as a white hat hacker
he or she is given authorization from
the company to perform security
assessments
and at the end an ethical hacker would
have to report the findings back to the
company
so that the vulnerabilities can be fixed
an ethical hacker performs these
security assessments with the help of
various hacking techniques
and tools let's now move on to our next
topic
that is the steps to become an ethical
hacker you might wonder how to start
your ethical hacking career right
well i will take you through that step
by step firstly the candidate must have
a computer science
or an information technology bachelor's
degree it is also possible to become an
ethical hacker without these degrees but
provided you have the required skill
sets and experience
the next requirement to be an ethical
hacker is that the candidate must have a
minimum of two years of experience
in the information security field you
have to start your career with a
software or a networking job
and only then can you move on to the
ethical hacking field
you have to start your career with a
software or a networking job and only
then can you move into the ethical
hacking field
coming to the certifications it is
necessary for the candidate to hold
various cyber security certifications
certifications play a vital role in the
field of cyber security your job
opportunities can solely depend on these
certifications
to become an ethical hacker you can
start off with the foundational level
certifications
such as the ccna and comptria security
plus certifications
finally the last step to become an
ethical hacker is to clear the certified
ethical hacker
examination ch certification is provided
by the ec council
it trains the candidate to protect a
company's network
by using the same tools and methods that
a hacker would use
the ch exam will have a duration of 4
hours
with 125 number of questions if the
candidate clears this
exam then he or she will become a
certified ethical hacker
now that you know the steps to become an
ethical hacker let's look into the skill
sets which are required to help you
achieve these steps
first and foremost an ethical hacker
needs to have an in-depth knowledge of
the working of the operating systems
knowledge of windows linux and macintosh
operating systems is required
for penetration testing creating
exploits and bug hunting
programming will be important so
knowledge of programming languages such
as cec
plus plus html python and php will be
very helpful
basic knowledge of networking tcp
protocols and osi model
is necessary as networking is the
foundation of cyber security
for securing databases knowledge of sql
nosql postgresql is necessary
cryptography is used to secure
information it is the process of
converting data from a readable format
to
a non-readable format and vice versa
cryptanalysis
is decryption without a secret key in
most cases
certified ethical hacker would need to
perform
cryptanalysis hence ethical hacker has
to be comfortable with
cryptography and cryptanalysis ethical
hackers
should be proficient in network security
control
measures such as intrusion detection and
intrusion prevention techniques
now let's move on to the
responsibilities which are taken care of
by an ethical hacker
let's have a look at these
responsibilities an ethical hacker is
responsible for scanning systems
open and closed ports using tools like
nessus and nmap vulnerabilities and
threats are identified by doing this
in addition to scanning for
vulnerabilities they also search the
deep corners of the network to spot
critical information such as passwords
which can make the organization
vulnerable to an attack
in addition to building and maintaining
ids ips
and firewalls they also try to evade
these security measures
to gauge the performance of the systems
a lot of times
a company's online fraud or online theft
incidents are looked into by an ethical
hacker
an ethical hacker also checks for
sniffing networks and hijacked web
servers and applications
those were the responsibilities of an
ethical hacker now let's look into the
various job roles an ethical hacker can
apply for
it is a misconception that an ethical
hacker will perform only penetration
testing
well there are a number of other jobs an
ethical hacker can apply for
the different job roles such as that of
a penetration tester
information security analyst security
consultant
and an information security manager
let's have a look at each of these job
roles one by one
a penetration tester performs the
typical responsibility of an ethical
hacker
that is he or she tries to exploit a
security system's vulnerabilities
this is carried out using different
hacking tools and techniques
an ethical hacker can also apply for the
role of an information security analyst
there is a difference between the job
rules of a penetration tester and that
of an information security analyst
here the candidate will be required to
primarily design and protect the
organization's network from various
cyber attacks
finally the candidate is also required
to document the identified security
breaches
so that it can be omitted the next time
the responsibilities of a security
consultant is more or less similar to
that of an information security analyst
that we saw previously
as a security consultant you will be
responsible to design
implement and maintain barrier security
architectures
in addition to this you're also required
to upgrade the security systems as and
when required
finally an ethical hacker can also apply
to the role of an information security
manager
as the name suggests this role will
require the candidate to possess
managerial skills as an information
security manager is responsible
to head the i.t and the information
security team
now that we have seen the
responsibilities the skills and the
steps to become an ethical hacker
let's have a look at the different
companies hiring ethical hackers
to name a few we have bank of america
ernest and young kpmg
urban pro and ibm let's now look into
the salary structure of an ethical
hacker
well in india the average annual salary
of a certified ethical hacker is nearly
4 lakhs 76 000 rupees and in the u.s the
average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker
is 91 000 now i will guide you through a
sample resume of a penetration tester
as you can see on your screens this is a
sample resume of a penetration tester
we will look into this resume closely
and understand how your resume should
look like
if you are applying for the role of a
penetration tester as always you can
start off with your name
and your email id and your phone number
followed by a brief summary of your
current job
profile it is prefer to add your
linkedin profile link here
and also your github profile link if you
have one
as i mentioned earlier this is a sample
resume for a penetration tester
and hence we have to have more than two
years of experience
in the information security field as you
can see under the experience section
the candidate has two prior experiences
out of which the first experience is
that of a software tester
and second is that of a penetration
tester you would have to mention your
latest or current
experience at the beginning you can
mention your job role
and the company and the duration under
which you can list out the various
responsibilities that you are looking
into currently if you are a penetration
tester
you can mention responsibilities such as
security monitoring
black box testing documentation of the
results
vulnerability scanning and so on below
this
you can mention your first company's
experience
with the roles and responsibilities that
you have performed earlier
here the candidate was a software tester
before becoming a penetration tester
let's move on to the education section
here the candidate holds a bachelor's
degree
in computer science you can mention your
degree followed by the university name
or if you're applying for any other role
in the cyber security domain it is
recommended that you
list out the certifications as well to
start off with a ccna certification
will be preferred followed by a
certified ethical hacker certification
which is a must
if you are applying for the role of a
penetration tester
in addition to it the certified expert
penetration tester certification will
also hold a great advantage
after mentioning the certifications you
can go ahead and mention your skill sets
here we have the technical skills and
non-technical skills under technical
skills you can mention the programming
languages that you know
here we have c c plus plus java perl you
can also mention the operating systems
that you have worked on for example
windows linux unix
and in addition to the programming
languages and the os you can also
mention
the tools that you know such as nmap
metasploit tools which will be helpful
if you are
applying for the role of a penetration
tester then you can also mention
encryption technologies
knowledge of sql and bug tracking
systems if you have worked on them
before
if you have participated in a code
authored you can mention that here as
well
under the non-technical skills you can
mention various
competitions that you have taken part in
and the games that you like
and other extracurricular activities
finally you can also mention the
projects undertaken
under the projects undertaken you can
talk about the various projects that you
have performed in your company
or outside the company here we have two
projects one
as a software test engineer and second
one as a penetration tester
so this is how a resume of a penetration
tester will look like
and with that we have come to the end of
this full course video on ethical
hacking
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
related to the ethical hacking topics
that were covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here